three two one
here we are again hey joe hello jordan
how are you doing man i'm doing great
you have uh
the schedule that you have and the
amount of energy and enthusiasm
you maintain with the schedule it is
very remarkable
because you're not stopping you're not
slowing down i mean you've you've had
your foot on the gas
for like two solid years now make hay
while the sun shines
i guess that was what it is is that how
you feel about it well you know when you
have an opportunity that's completely
preposterous you're a fool to take it
for granted
yeah and i guess that's so and yeah so
tammy and i have been to 100 cities
since january
so everywhere you know and part of what
keeps us going well first of all i have
a really good crew
you know like the caa guys they're
really good live nation's been really
good
they make sure the theaters are smooth
and and we've had no
problems at all and then i have lots of
people who are helping me with my
scheduling and tammy travels with me
and then the the lectures themselves
well i really like doing them partly
because i do a different lecture every
night
and so that keeps me sharp and it makes
sure that i'm thinking about new things
all the time and trying to formulate my
thoughts more precisely
and they're also unbelievably positive
so that's also that that's also
something that makes it a lot easier to
to do because you know i go to a city
and there's
1500 to 2 000 people waiting for me
there which is like
staggering in and of itself wherever i
go
and they're all there listening intently
and and
it's it's a sophisticated discussion or
at least as sophisticated as i can make
it and i'm communicating directly with
the audience and
all the people are there to try to get
their lives together and so
the the the feeling in the in the hall
is really really positive and then i
usually talk to about 150 people
afterwards
and you know they're they all of them
all of them
well many of them you know they just say
hi and they're polite and we have a
photograph and all that but lots of them
have stories about
how they've been putting their lives
together and they're thrilled to death
about it you know that they're out of
the hole they were in
or they've started a new business or
they've sold a new business or they just
decided to get married or they're going
to have some kids or
they've fixed up their relationship with
their parents or they quit drinking
or and they're they're not addicted i
talked to one guy in europe
he'd stopped he was he was addicted i
don't remember what to but it wasn't it
was something that wasn't good
he he'd stopped for nine months and got
nine of his friends to quit too
so he comes up he's just like bouncing
you know he's so damn happy that
his life is better and not only that
that he had this additional positive
effect on other people so
and it's so fun because i have these
conversations with people they're brief
but they're very personal and they're
very intense you know because
they they you think people have to trust
you
to tell you that their lives weren't
going so well and then they have to
trust you even more to tell you that
they're going better now because
of course what you want when you tell
someone that things are going better is
you want
real encouragement and real sense from
the person you're talking to that
they're happy for you
and i'm absolutely thrilled to hear
these things like i was in
whole foods this morning i went down
near where i'm staying
and two of the guys that worked behind
the meet counter came out to talk to me
and independently and they'd both been
reading my books and watching my
lectures and one of them said he
had a seven-year-old son he really
wanted to do right by him he was looking
for ethical and moral guidance and
you know he found the books really
helpful and then it was helping him put
his life together and
and so car guy at the car rental place
last night told me the same thing and
so it's so exciting it's so ridiculously
exciting
to go everywhere around the world and to
go into airports or to walk down the
street
and have people come up and say um i've
been watching you on youtube they often
mention you
i've been listening to what you say i've
been developing a vision for my life
it's really helped me out a lot thanks a
lot and
jesus like to be able to have that
happen
you know time after time day after day
all over the place that's just
absolutely it makes going to 100 cities
like continually
uh energizing because it's so positive
and so and then there's all this weird
crap in the press you know about my
dangerous followers and all this
alt-right nonsense and
it's so ridiculous you know i've talked
to 250
000 people in in in seven months we
haven't had one
incident that was negative in that
entire time not
one nothing no misbehavior on anyone's
part
we had one heckler who was obviously not
a fan of mine
given that he was a heckler that was it
other than that
the audiences behave perfectly they all
dress up they come in suits which is
really cool a lot of the young guys they
dress up
so they have a little suit competition
with me which is quite fun so that's an
additional bonus and
yeah it's it's pretty damn good joe
i think it's really fantastic and i
think what's going on is uh
it makes me very optimistic because i
think that
one of the things that new media has
provided is these
new avenues for information to get out
there
and these new things like these lecture
circuits
when was the last time you saw public
lecture circuits that were popular to
the tune of
thousands and thousands of people i saw
the ones that you and sam harris did on
youtube
and you know sam's doing them with a lot
of other people as well you're doing
them with the bottom
people with dave rubin as well yeah
these are i mean this is a very unique
thing
that's for sure and also this desire to
understand
new paths of behavior and patterns of
thinking
and that these are corrective paths and
patterns that can lead you to a more
fulfilled and happier life
and and recognize the pitfalls of
certain types of behavior that people
just fall into
yeah and i think oftentimes the
difference between someone who lives a
fulfilled life
and someone who lives a life filled with
disaster
is following incorrect patterns and not
knowing what the correct
ones are so there's a lot of good people
out there that live
shitty lives and they don't do it
because they're they're just
dumb or because they're bad they do it
because they've been
influenced by certain patterns they've
fallen into patterns whether it's
because
of the people that they surround
themselves with or the the neighborhood
that grew up the the people that around
them
have this way of being and they kind of
fall into that or it's drugs or it's
alcohol or whatever it is
but then they find a new one yeah and
then they can slide right into that
new one and all of a sudden they feel
energized when they wake up in the
morning instead of hungover
they're getting exercise in they're
eating healthy they're starting to think
about things correctly and do
good things and the momentum of them
doing those good things
leads them to feel good about themselves
and energized and this is these are all
things that you
promote and that i think are genuinely
really
significant yeah like really important
but it gets
but the thing is it gets maligned it
gets you get pushed into this
weird but what we were talking about
before the podcast is by a small select
group of people
it's a very small but vocal minority
that wants to misrepresent you yeah and
then there's
the periphery that listen to this small
group
and then they sort of parrot those words
out without any real thinking about what
you've said
well you know one of the things that i
have made a mistake about in the past
that i just realized in the last couple
of weeks was that you know people
often accuse me and they say well most
of the people that listen to you are men
and i think and that you know when
you're accused like that your automatic
response is well you wouldn't be accused
if you weren't doing something wrong
so there must be something wrong about
that it's like why isn't it 50 women and
so i've said things like well
you know 80 of the people who watch
youtube videos are men
and so the fact that 80 of the people
who watch my
videos are men isn't that surprising
given that base rate
but then about three weeks ago i started
thinking what what the hell am i doing
it's like
what is there something wrong with
talking to men is that actually a
problem
it's like i'm trying to i'm trying to i
mean i didn't set out to do that
specifically but if that's the way it's
working out and
and there is a majority of men coming to
my shows say
then is that why is that's all of a
sudden supposed to be a bad thing
i'm asking men to you know to be more
honest
and especially in their speech and their
thinking and to be more responsible for
themselves and for their family and for
their community
and to grow up and to shoulder their
burden and to live a responsible and
meaningful life and putting those two
things together conceptually and it's
like
and then there's an accusation about
that as if there's something wrong and i
thought
why am i even playing into this it's
like fine i'm talking to men
i'm encouraging them and i am absolutely
thrilled like every time someone comes
up to me
and that's happening i mean maybe a
hundred times a week or something like
that and tells me
one of these stories about how they put
their life together it's like
i'm absolutely thrilled about that and
so i don't see
it's just a sign of how pathological our
times have become in some sense that
there would have been any guilt about
that to begin with
because how is that not a good thing man
it's weird
uh i think a lot of that has to do with
this concept that
men are running everything and that men
have this massive advantage
there's a white male advantage and
privilege that we all
enjoy and share and that men have this
advantage financially there's disparity
in terms of the
the gender gap and pay you know and
income
and that if you were really a good
person you would be
looking out you would be trying to
balance that out and yeah you wouldn't
be
trying to pump up the winning team right
so that's the funny thing
well that's it and that's part of that
narrative that well if there's winners
there
there has to be losers and the reason
that there are losers is because there's
winners
and that's complete bloody nonsense
because as far as i'm concerned that and
i really believe this is that every
single person
who sets out to put themselves together
ethically
is a net positive to everyone around
them there's no downside to that
you know my book has been criticized by
people who've read it very poorly
especially chapter one when i talk about
hierarchies
that i'm somehow supporting the idea
that
power in a hierarchy is the right way to
be and that's
there's absolutely nothing and what i've
written that suggests that at all like
i'm suggesting that human hierarchies
are very complex and that
the way that you win in a human
hierarchy is by being
competent and reciprocal and so and so i
mean for example
even if you're selfish let's say you got
to think very carefully about what that
would mean if you were selfish and awake
because
you have to work to take care of
yourself and what you want say
in this moment but then there's you
tomorrow and there's you next week and
there's you next month
the next year and 10 years from now and
when you're old so
because you're self-conscious and
because you're aware of the future
you're actually a community
unto yourself and if you're selfish and
impulsive all that means is that you're
serving
the person you are right now you know in
that impulsive way but not the person
you're going to be
and so that's not a good grounds for any
sort of ethical behavior
and i see that if you serve yourself
properly
there's no difference between that
serving your family properly and serving
your community properly those things all
mesh in a kind of a harmonious manner
and
one of the things that's really being
effective in the lecture tour is
a discussion about that idea and its
relationship between
the relationship between that and
meaning and responsibility because
one of the things that strikes the
audience is silent
constantly because i'm always listening
to them to see you know when when the
attention is maximally focused is
whenever i point out to people that the
antidote to the meaninglessness of their
life and the suffering
and the malevolence that they might be
displaying because they're resentful and
bitter about how things have turned
out the antidote to that is to take on
more responsibility
for themselves and for other people and
that that's aspirational
which is kind of cool you know the
conservative types
the duty types and i'm not complaining
about them you know that they're always
basically saying well
this is how you should act because in
some sense that's your duty right that's
how a good citizen would act
and that's a reasonable argument but the
case that i've been making is more that
well there is a there is value
distinctions between things
some things are worth doing and some
things aren't and you can kind of
discover
what that is for yourself and then you
should aim at the things that are most
worth doing
and what you'll find if you watch
carefully is that
the things that you find worth doing are
almost always associated with an
increase in responsibility because if
you think about the people you admire
for example you spontaneously admire
people and that's a manifestation of the
instinct to imitate
and people are very imitative you don't
admire people who don't take care of
themselves
like unless there's something wrong with
you you at least want
an admirable person to be accountable
for themself
and then if they've got something left
over so they can be accountable for
their family well then that's a net plus
obviously that's someone you think is
solid and then maybe they take care of
some more people they have a business or
they're involved in the community in
some positive way you see well that's a
person whose
pattern of being is worth imitating and
so and that's all associated with
responsibility and
it's so interesting because it's as if
it's as if
everybody kind of knows this but that it
hasn't crystallized it's like
well you should be responsible because
that's what a good citizen is it's not
no no
you should be responsible because you
need to have a deep meaning in your life
to offset the suffering so you don't get
bitter
and the way you do that is to bear a
heavy load you know to get yourself
in in check for you now and for you in
the future and then to do the same for
your family and your community and that
there's real nobility in that and
there's real meaning
and more the other thing that i've been
suggesting to people and i also believe
this is that
and i think that the guys that have come
to talk to me especially the ones that
have had real
real rough lives they really understand
this if you don't get your act together
and you let yourself slide
then what kind of moves in to take the
place of what you could have been is
something that's really not good at all
so it's not only that if you're living a
like a dissolute life
that you're not aiming at anything
positive and so you don't have any real
meaning and you're subsumed by anxiety
and all of that hopelessness
but something kind of hellish moves in
there too to to occupy that place and so
then you end up making
things worse and when you know one of
the things i learned about studying
totalitarian systems
whether they were on the right or the
left was that part of the reason that
the totalitarian horrors of the 20th
century manifested themselves was
because average people didn't
take on the proper responsibility they
shut their eyes when their eyes should
have been open
even though they knew it and they didn't
said things they knew they shouldn't
have done and said
and that was what supported those
horrible systems so
you know if you don't get your act
together then you leave a little space
for hell
and i really believe that don't you
think
when things are happening like something
like nazi germany i i
i would imagine that during that time
the people that were not
in support of it felt helpless whether
you're you're in
germany you're a part of this country
this country is turning
towards this horrible situation where
jewish people are being put on trains
and you know
the people that didn't speak out in that
i don't necessarily know if it's a lack
of discipline
or just complete fear and paralysis
it's a fear for sure i mean no knowledge
of how to deal with it
disbelief
well that's the thing the problem is
that if you're going to forestall that
sort of thing you have to do it early
you know because the longer you wait the
higher the price you pay for it but
isn't it
it's hard to take that jump early
because you're not exactly sure where
it's going
that's true and you're entering well and
you're also likely to be
jumped on i mean you can see that
happening in our own culture you know
you make a mistake on twitter or even
something that isn't a mistake and you
know you can pay a
well what feels to be a pretty high
price right now whether it is a high
price or not is hard to tell because
twitter is so
weirdly fictional you know it's so hard
to to
to get your to get a grasp on exactly
what's going on
what's it it's also your comprehension
of what what is the
your emotional reaction to people that
you don't know
being mean to you like this is like what
is that price
well and people some people want to
dismiss that as being not
just nothing it's not not that big a
deal but it is a big deal it causes
people to commit suicide
i mean it has absolutely bullying online
has caused many people to commit suicide
well the thing is you know when you
the weird thing about that online
communication is that like i find that i
tend to react to a negative twitter
comment
as if it's someone sitting across from
me talking to me that i know
now it's not and i don't even know if
the person is real
or because the accounts are often
anonymous right so that person isn't
really real
but your emotional response is still
well someone's gone out of their way
to be harshly critical to you right you
know and that doesn't happen that often
in your day-to-day life and so
you know if you're a reasonable person
you're very sensitive to
criticism right because it's rare and
because you might be wrong
especially if there's a lot of people
criticizing you because you kind of have
to be psychopathic in order just to
brush that off you know it's like
well a hundred people think i'm wrong
there's nothing to that it's like
well if it's a hundred people out of a
hundred million
but you can't tell on twitter right then
it's irrelevant but
if it's a mob of 100 people that show up
outside your house which is quite kind
of what twitter feels like then you
think well god you know
i must have done something wrong because
otherwise why would all these people be
here
right you know and i think that's why so
many people are driven to apologize
you know when they when they do
something on twitter and or do something
and then the twitter
mobs go after them they think oh god i
must have done something wrong i should
i should you know do some soul searching
and yeah so some of that's not even fear
it's more like
it's it's in a sense it's a morality
that's misplaced
because of our inability to calibrate
the the social messaging
i mean i've stopped almost completely
stopped reading
twitter comments in the last month and
i'm definitely better for happier it
yeah
it's just it's too much it's too much
it's too crazy
what is your number up to now the number
of followers about a million on twitter
that's
that's when it's about time to get out
of dodge yeah yeah well i mean
and i'm still following people and
reading what people are posting but no
the comments i'm just
i'm just not worth it no it's not and i
think it does have something to do with
the technology itself like i do believe
that that
small limit um facilitates
angry impulsive responding so you're
trying to get people to respond to you
but the
alternative is facebook where you have
these long
posts that are just rambling
first drafts that people put out like
when they get go
when they start ranting about politics
or what have you i just can't get
involved
they're just too big and then people
jump in and comment on them and often
their comments are massive as well
it's just too verbose whereas the good
thing about twitter is it makes you
boil down what you're trying to say to a
very succinct thing
although i do enjoy when someone has a
good twitter thread
like there was a really good twitter
thread what was that gentleman's name
respectable lawyer
respectable law he wrote a long history
of the sentinelese people that um
that you know that's that uncontacted
tribe uh
in the indian sea where they uh this
gentleman went there to try to
commission
christianity and shot him full of arrows
yeah and he wrote this long history of
these people and what what
kind of what they've had to endure with
being you know a few people
going to them and doing some awful
thought things and diseases and stuff
like that
so i enjoy when someone will do that
like these long like every now and then
someone will use it in a novel way
i really like that but there's um you
know a lot of it is just people just
trying to get a reaction and what's the
reaction they can get by pissing you off
that's like the best one
well they also might be the ones that
are most like we don't
exactly know what motivates people to
respond on twitter and it might be that
the fundamental motivation for a twitter
response is anger
yeah you know rather than the desire to
share something because we don't know
anything about how these new
communication techniques function
psychologically
like maybe twitter is skewed 90 towards
people who are
impulsively angry at that moment it
could easily be
we don't know like you know if you're
driving in your car and someone cuts you
off you curse
you know or at least i do and and it's
often
a situational issue rather than a
personality flaw on the part of the
other driver even though it's easy to
assume that
but you respond impulsively i mean god
only knows how
how much of our social media networks
are set up to differentially
um reward impulsive behavior and it's
also not that easy to hold people
accountable in some sense
and maybe there's some utility to that
but with anonymous accounts and all of
that the anonymity is also
problematic because it certainly enables
people to allow their worst to manifest
themselves
especially if they're resentful and
angry so the only benefit that i can see
to anonymity
is it gives you the opportunity to
explore controversial ideas without
bullying true
true true i think it's used correctly
well that's it i think that that's true
i think there's there's some utility i
mean i don't think that it should be
forbidden
but well like most things it's ha it has
its advantages and its disadvantages
like most things it's not entirely
negative to be anonymous hey so i
figured something out that i thought i'd
tell you about
this took me like 30 years to figure out
and i figured it out on this tour
so there's this old idea you know that
you have to rescue your father from the
belly of the whale right
from some monster that's deep in the
abyss you see that pinocchio for example
but
it's a very common idea and i figured
out why that is i think
so imagine that we already know from a
clinical perspective that
you know if you set out a path towards a
goal which
you want to do because you need a goal
and you need a path
because that provides you with positive
emotion right so you set up something as
valuable so that implies a hierarchy
you set up something as valuable you
decide that you're going to do that
instead of other things so that's kind
of a sacrifice
because you're sacrificing everything
else to pursue that and then
you experience a fair bit of positive
emotion and meaning as you watch
yourself move towards the goal
and so the implication of that is the
the better the goal the
the more full and rich your experience
is going to be when you pursue it
so that's one of the reasons of of
that's one of the reasons for developing
a vision
and for fleshing yourself out
philosophically because you want to aim
at the highest goal that you can manage
okay so you do that and then what you'll
find is that as you move towards the
goal there are certain things that
that that you have to accomplish that
frighten you you know
maybe you have to learn to be a better
speaker a better writer a better thinker
you have to be better to people around
you or you have to learn some new skills
and you're afraid of that
whatever because it's going to stretch
you if you if you pursue a goal and it's
and so that'll put you up against
challenges
okay so all the clinical data indicates
well the opposite of safe spaces as
jonathan height has been pointing out
that
what you want to do when you identify
something that someone is avoiding that
they need to do because they're afraid
you have them voluntary voluntarily
confronted and so you break it down
what you try to do if you're a behavior
therapist is you break down the thing
they're avoiding into smaller and
smaller pieces
until you find a piece that's small
enough so they'll do it and it doesn't
really matter as long as they start it
you know then they can put the next
piece on the next piece and what happens
is
they don't get less afraid exactly they
get braver
they get they get it's like there's more
of them and you can and here's why so
imagine
you do something new and that's
informative
right there's information in the action
and then you can incorporate that
information and turn it into a skill and
turn it into a transformation of your
perceptions
so there's more to you because you've
tried something new so that's one thing
but the second thing is and there's good
biological evidence for this now that
if you put yourself in a new situation
then new
genes code for new proteins and build
new neural structures
and new nervous system structures same
thing happens to some degree when you
work out right because your
your muscles are responding to the load
but your nervous system does that too so
you imagine that
there's a lot of potential you locked in
your genetic
code and then if you put yourself in a
new situation then
then the stress that's the situational
stress that's produced by that
particular situation
unlocks those genes and then builds new
parts of you and so that's very cool
because who knows how much there is
locked inside of you okay so now here's
the idea
so let's assume that that scales
as you take on heavier and heavier loads
that more and more of you you get more
and more informed because you're doing
more and more difficult things
but more and more of you gets unlocked
and so then what that would imply is
that
if you got to the point where you could
look at the darkest thing so that would
be the abyss right that would be the
deepest abyss if you could look at the
harshest things like the most
brutal parts of the suffering of the
world and the malevolence of people and
society
if you could look that look at that
straight and
and directly that that would turn you on
maximally
and so that's the idea of rescuing your
father because
imagine that you're like the potential
composite of
of all your all the ancestral wisdom
that's locked inside of you
biologically but that's not going to
come out at all
unless you stress yourself unless you
unless you challenge yourself
and the bigger the challenge you take on
the more that's going to turn on
and so that as you take on a broader and
broader range of challenges
and you push yourself harder then more
and more of what you could be
turns on and that's equivalent to
transforming yourself into the ancestral
father
into all because you're you're like the
what would you call it you're the
consequence of all these
living beings that have come before you
and that's all
part of your biological potentiality and
then if you can push yourself then all
that clicks on
and that turns you into who you could be
that's and that's the re-representation
of that
positive ancestral father so that's why
you rescue your father from the belly of
the beast
so you think that this ultimate goal of
sac of sacrifice and of of risking your
life
in order to save someone who's truly
important to you
that this somehow or another maximizes
your potential as a human being well i
think i think you can think about it
religiously too so
think about it this way so in in the
christian story for example you have
christ does two things that are
messianic one is takes the suffering of
the world unto himself
because that's a weird idea okay so what
does that mean let's think about it
psychologically well maybe it means that
well that's your job is the world's full
of suffering
and you should accept that as your
responsibility past present and future
you're supposed to do something about
that as much as you can about it and
maybe you start with your own
localized suffering you know put
yourself together but
then you expand that outward and you
decide that it's you're not a victim
of that even though you know you're part
and parcel of it
but you're you're the potential solution
to that
and so you accept that as a
responsibility so that's part of taking
on a load that's part of bearing across
you could look at it that way the cross
is sort of a symbol of the place of
maximal suffering
okay so you accept that as a challenge
not as a
not as something that you're victimized
by maybe you accept that as the price of
being
okay so that's one that's one
responsibility
you're responsible for addressing the
suffering in the world so that could
give you some meaning
seems to me then the next thing is
there's a story of course that christ
met the devil in the desert and so
that's the encounter with malevolence
so that would be the other thing because
the two major problems that people face
obviously are suffering
tragedy and malevolence and so that's
the other thing that you're responsible
for
is that you're supposed to look at the
capacity for human evil
as clearly as you possibly can which is
a very terrifying thing you know that
causes post-traumatic stress disorder in
people that aren't
accustomed to it and in the mythology
that's associated with the encounter
with evil
it's almost always the case that the
entity that
does the encountering even if it does it
voluntarily
is is is
hurt by it so the egyptian god horus for
example who's the i
and the falcon the thing that can see
and pay attention when he encounters his
evil uncle
seth who's the precursor of satan he
loses an eye
because it's no joke to encounter
malevolence you know it can really shake
you
but the idea would be that if you can
face the
malevolence and you can face the
suffering then that maximally
that opens the door to your maximal
potential and then the op
the optimistic part of that is then this
is
this is why it's so useful to peer into
the darkness let's say
the optimistic part of that is is that
although the suffering is great and the
malevolence is
is deep your capacity to transcend it is
stronger
so what you get out of the most negative
viewpoint
is the most positive possible
consequence because one of the things
you'd like to know if you wanted to know
something deep about yourself is that
you could face the worst that there was
and prevail
and i believe that's cape i believe
that's care i believe that that
people are capable of that i think that
despite how tragic life is and how
malevolent
things are that fundamentally our
spirit let's say has the capacity to
to confront that and to fix it
like psychologically to confront it
courageously to be able to bear up under
that if you do it voluntarily
but also to address it not only to deal
with it psychologically but to deal with
it practically
and that we could make things much
better there's always a striving towards
utopia right like this is the ultimate
goal that if
you you ask people what would you like
out of civilization well i'd like
everyone to be happy and everyone to get
along and there'd be no war
nothing no suffering no anything but
in order to really truly learn about
yourself and about life you have to
overcome adversity you have to
experience things
and i firmly believe that in order to
truly appreciate
love you have to understand and really
have felt hate
and to really appreciate camaraderie you
have to feel loneliness so
this is just a part of being a person
for whatever reason
like yeah well maybe see the other thing
that i've been thinking along the same
lines is that
you know it isn't so in the in the
biblical stories
in abrahamic stories for example abraham
basically hangs around his
dad's tent till he's like 80. he's one
of these guys that fails to launch you
know in a big way
and god eventually gets sick and tired
of him like you know playing video games
in his basement and says
get the hell out there into the world
and and have a life and so
he does he leaves his his father's tent
his community and his and his country
which is what he's commanded to do
and then he goes out and has an
adventure but you know the first thing
he encounters is a famine and then he
encounters a tyranny and then he
encounters
a bunch of people in the tyrannical
state that want to take his wife
and so you can imagine that abraham's
response to that is like it was a hell
of a lot better
sitting in my dad's tent playing video
games but what's cool about that story
what i realized when i was doing
the lectures on it last year was that
that was a call to adventure
you know and and that the right way of
conceptualizing what we're talking about
isn't that
utopia would be a place where everyone
was happy because because
and i think because of what you just
laid out is you need that polarity
you know and people need a load and we
need adversity
and we need difficulty we need all of
that um
so maybe what you want is an adventure
the greatest adventure that you could
have
and that would involve you know
something to push against it would
involve real challenge
and so just a a see dostoevsky knew this
because when he wrote
notes from underground which i would
highly recommend to everyone who's
listening it's a great book and it's a
very short book
he he criticized socialist utopia
back in like 1860 way before it became
the sort of widespread idea that that it
is now
and what dostoevsky said was that while
human beings are these very
peculiar creatures and if you gave us a
utopia so that
we had nothing to do but eat cake and
busy ourselves with the continuation of
the species that was
that was his line um that the first
thing we do is smash it all to bits just
so that something
unexpected and and and troublesome would
happen because we're built for adventure
and not for
peace and happiness well we're designed
to overcome the natural world
the natural world is filled with that
the natural world is filled with things
trying to eat things
this is just everywhere you look that's
all you observe you observe predators
and prey and animals eating vegetables
and that's it
and i think that this this concept of
overcoming adversity is so
it's so human it's so a part of what we
are that i want to bring it back to you
because one of the things that i've been
considering is that i've said this
many times and i just had a conversation
with my good friend steve vanello the
other day where he brought it up
independently
he said i think jordan peterson is the
most misunderstood and misinterpreted
guy in the world
he's like people are always like not
just mr but
but misstating what you believe in
misdating what you say
this opposition to you this uh i mean
like we were talking about this gq
interview which i thought was
uh i thought that woman was far more
intelligent
than the and her approach was far better
and far more reasoned and
well thought out than some of the other
attacks on you before so they're
bringing in the varsity level players
that's what i'm saying it's like
but i think this is important i think
this is
part of what with what
forges this message is that you are
and you you and this one of the things
that eric weinstein and i
had said about you is that you're
essentially the the hoist gracie of the
intellectual dark web
if you don't know what that means is the
early days of the ufc
no one knew what the best martial art
was
and the idea was like there was all
these martial arts that are running
around independently
and they were all claiming that they had
the best technique
and let's see what happens and hoist
gracie was the one who represented jiu
jitsu
and went out there and beat all these
people with superior technique and
superior strategy
south american yes he's from brazil
brazil yeah okay i know about him yeah
and he
launched this brazilian jew and his
family
launched this brazilian jiu jitsu empire
that has since taken over the world of
martial arts
but you are the one who's consistently
engaging in these people you're the one
who's involved these
valley tudo events where you're debating
these people who are coming at you
hostile with notes and i think
is as uncomfortable as those moments are
like who was the woman
that said so what you're trying to say
is kathy newman yeah
her i think her approach i think she
misunderestimated you i think she
underestimated you i think she
misinterpreted
who you are and she thought that she
could come at you with this
straw man sort of article and uh
argument rather and frame your positions
in a
very unflattering way it just didn't
work no it just was
it was like the early days of hois
gracie guys would come at him flailing
and get him in an arm bar and they'd tap
out and they'd go [ __ ]
that's kind of what happened with you
but now this woman who you
had this conversation with in gq she was
much more skilled yeah she was
better verbally she was she her
arguments made more sense
yeah she seemed more reasonable more
well-read yeah she was able to think on
her feet quicker
but still these are really important
conversations well
it was a funny day because i went to the
to the
hotel room in baltimore you know and i
went out of my way to do it and
um she was hostile to me the second i
walked into the room
really yes and and that really kind of
put me off
how so well she basically told me that
we were going to have a war
you know not so many words that that but
just there was a coldness to her
and uh a distaste for me that was sort
of radiating from her
so she had a she was animus possessed
from a union perspective
that's the right way of thinking about
it one of the ways of thinking about
that is that she had a chip on her
shoulder in relationship to me
so she'd already formulated who i was in
her imagination
and she it was also maybe a form of
projection so like i was the embodiment
of all the things that she found
distasteful
and that's who she was so there was no
there was no
willingness to consider on her part that
i could be
different than her preconceptions of
right and so she was she was
hostile to me in the way that you would
be if you were prejudiced against
someone right from the beginning
and so by the time it was uncomfortable
in the room
and by the time and there was a photo
shoot and so by the time the
conversation started
i was more impatient than i would
normally be because
one of the things that i do expect from
journalists and kathy newman was like
this by the way and and so
some of the other people that gone have
gone after me at least
they had the professionalism to be civil
before the interview started you know
like because
there's a certain amount of politeness i
would say that
not that i'm owed but that someone
you're interviewing is owed
if they come out of their way to go talk
to you it's like it's just human decency
yes there's no there's no real conflict
right until you have this conflict
it's just hello nice to meet you yes
thank you for coming to human beings
interacting with each other yes
yes on on on well on relatively
professional well even just professional
right even just professional grounds
it's like
well we're both here to do a job and
i've agreed to come but
but knows the the there was palpable
enmity in the air right to begin with
and
you know when i actually thought at the
end of that interview i thought geez you
know maybe i'm
maybe i've done enough interviews
because i found that i was more
impatient than i would have liked to
have been now
luckily it doesn't seem to have gone
overboard because i've been watching the
comments on that gq
interview and i think it's got about
four and a half million views some
ridiculous number of views
and people have said that i was more
impatient
and a little harsher than usual which i
think is true
and i thought god you know maybe i'm
starting to run out of patience
which isn't good right right i don't
want to run out of patience because then
it
it will flavor the message
that you're putting out definitely and
people will take it in the wrong way and
they'll take it in with that bitterness
yes exactly well
you know one one of the things that i
think is very important is that you
don't become
uh resentful like and and well and and
you know
when i'm on this tour for example like
there's no resentment for me
because you think well this is you might
think well this is a lot of work and
i've been running around like mad
and and uh you know it takes a lot of
organization and it's quite demanding
and all of that
and that's all true and that none of
that is a complaint
and i decided with tammy right at the
beginning that
well first of all that this was going to
be work and not a vacation because we're
not stupid we know
you can't have everything at the same
time if you have any sense you're lucky
if you get some things that are good at
once you know
so we're very grateful to have that
opportunity and that
i was going to continue to do this as
long as i was thrilled
to be in front of the audience and then
when i meet people afterwards that i'm
not looking at the end of the line to
see when the night ends you know because
i want to be sure that
every single person that comes to meet
me i'm
you know present present for absolutely
because i am i am
actually quite taken aback and
thrilled i guess is the right word
grateful that's better
that they're there it's like god man
some of these people you know like i was
in
they're coming from all over the place
you know people flying from australia
into europe they've flown they've flown
lots of eastern europeans came
to england in fact they're making huge
treks there's guys who came from like
eight
they took them like 12 hours to get
through russia to come
to finland to watch the talk there you
know and
and then not just a few people like that
people are really going way the hell out
of their way
you know and then and then they line up
and it's not that it's not inexpensive
because these venues are expensive and
and all of that and i'm
well i'm i'm do it and it's the same
with the damn interviews it's like
i'm doing my best to not take any of
this for granted and not
get annoyed about it and and that goes
for the conflict too it's like
well you know
i've tried to have my agent screen out
maybe the more egregious
interviews you know the ones that would
just be nothing but combat because
they're i find them quite stressful
though i wouldn't say i'm hiding from
them
but you don't know to begin with how an
interview is going to go and i could
just say well
i'm done having interviews for a while
but i i can't help but see that the
conflict is a necessary part of this
even though i don't find it pleasant
like people think
they accuse me of being a provocateur of
enjoying the conflict
it's actually not true at all i don't
enjoy it at all it usually takes me
about three days to recover from a
like a particularly contentious
interview you know because i find it
i find conflict interpersonal conflict
quite stressful yes
you know but i think everyone does yes
and to pretend you don't
you're either a sociopath or you're a
liar yes yes well there are people who
seem to enjoy that kind of intellectual
combat you know that they yeah
and the political types are more like
that but but i think they still
afterwards feel it and if they read the
comments and
people are against them it's just that
the unease it carries
well you would think so i mean i don't
even know how people deal with it
because i mean
i'm being fortunate because although you
know i've had a fair
bit of negative press coverage the
comments
in on youtube in particular which is
where the bulk of the mar
and and i would say among the general
public have been overwhelmingly positive
i don't know what the hell it would be
like to be in a world where that was
reversed where
you know the majority of people are
against you i've seen jesus
i've seen it happen with guests that
i've had on the show where i've met them
afterwards and you see a physical effect
on them
you see them beating down like jesus
christ those comments are so mean i'm
like you can't read those you can't read
those
and you see how it's affecting them like
they can't sleep they really oh yeah it
[ __ ] with them they'll stay up for
nights
you know it's not good it's it's you're
you're you're taking in
all of these opinions of hundreds if not
thousands of people that you don't even
know you don't know if they're coming
from a healthy place and
and most of those opinions they would
not express it that way if they were
talking to you yeah
if they could get the same message
across like i think you were ignorant to
these facts
i think you are biased in your
perceptions even if they had
a an opinion that was unflattering the
way they'd
express it to you they'd be considerate
about you and your
your feelings as a human being and if
they weren't you wouldn't take into
consideration what they're saying
because
this guy's just an [ __ ] yeah right
but when you just see it in type
we just see print it just doesn't it
just it
it could be a smart person it could be a
psycho it could be a fool
it could be anything well it's also
funny too because
that the negative comments that are part
of social
media seem to be just as potent as
negative comments in real life but the
positive comments don't seem to be as
positive as the positive comments in
real life yes
like and i don't they don't seem as real
and i guess that's partly because we're
wired you know to be more sensitive to
threat and to negative emotion because
well because we're we can be hurt well
it's also healthy too to not stroke your
ego too much if you're just like
concentrating only on the like
like there's something distasteful if
you go to someone's page and they just
retweet all the positive things that
people say to them
because then it has this sort of
reinforcing site like people know that i
say something really positive to jordan
he's going to retweet me
there are some people that they engage
in this sort of commerce
you know like you say something positive
they retweet you
and you know it's it's a little it's a
little too strokey
right right people get really into that
stroking their own back yeah yeah well i
guess
yeah i guess the danger of that is that
possibility of
of that ego inflation that you really
want to avoid because that's a bad idea
yes
that's a very bad idea you've done a
wonderful job of avoiding those waters
because this is a new
this for a guy who's in his 50s
who becomes famous out of nowhere and
doesn't just become fame
just just become famous but becomes this
culturally significant sort of lightning
rod
i mean that that's how i view you and a
lot of these talks you're doing a lot of
these
these debates like you're having with
this woman at gq or some of your your
interviews
what you're doing is you're expressing
yourself
in a brave but very controversial way
and a lot of people are paying attention
to this but then you're backing it up
with your research you're backing it up
with real science you're backing up with
a tremendous amount of history of
of of the the human race and of religion
and of the scientific studies that have
been done that
show correlations between different
types of behaviors and human beings and
all this is rich it's it's very it's
very rewarding if you could take it all
in but when it goes against what people
have their preconceived notions or their
own set of beliefs that they're bringing
to
your conversations into your debates
then it creates this
hostile battle where
what you're saying is is is very
contrary
to what the way they've been living
their life or the really
really saw that in scandinavia
scandinavia yeah well i i was there
i went to stockholm twice in oslo twice
in helsinki twice and
and and copenhagen once in the last
month
and i spent quite a bit of a lot of
interviews
um and a lot of discussion about the
so-called gender paradox
that's a very interesting thing because
it's really put their tails in and not
in scandinavia
and and that makes sense because the
scandinavians are going to have to deal
with this
first because they've gone the farthest
down the
road for like making their society
gender equal but explain that to people
yeah they don't mind i will i will okay
so
so imagine first of all that there's two
kinds of equality that
you might pursue one would be equality
of opportunity
and so that would mean that um you know
there's
there's wide range of talent across
people regardless of their
type whatever that might be sex
gender race ethnicity there's there's
talent
distributed everywhere and it's
a kind of a truism and i would say a
truism of the west in the deepest sense
that
each of the individuals within those
groups should be put in a position where
they their talents are they're
encouraged to manifest those talents
partly because that would be good for
them spiritually and psychologically but
also because that would be of obvious
benefit to the community
right i mean talent's rare which people
don't understand
there's lots of different kinds of
talent but it's but in each domain it's
rare
and so it's to everyone's benefit to
exploit
talented people to the maximal possible
degree so even if you're just
selfish you'd want to push for equality
of opportunity because
the more talented people there are out
there the more cool stuff you get to
have and
hopefully the the more diverse and
interesting your life is so
so you can pursue equality of
opportunity um policies
and the scandinavians have done that
especially trying to knock down barriers
for women in the workplace and by all
accounts
by all standard theories the
scandinavian countries in places like
like like the netherlands canada to to a
slightly lesser degree
have done uh have gone farther than any
other countries
in pursuing those um policies
okay and and and part of the consequence
of that is that
some of the differences between men and
women have been
um minimized so obviously there's far
more women in the workplace than there
were 40 years ago
and in many occupations there's actually
dominance by women there's dominance in
the universities there's dominance in
the health care fields and so
women have poured into the workplace and
hypothetically
there's problems with that because it's
put a lot of stress on family structure
but hypothetically that's for the best
and
because it gives people a broader range
of choices and it gives everyone access
to more talent so
and then also if you look around the
world you see that one of the best
predictors of
of the probability of economic
development in developing countries
is their attitude is the attitude in
those countries towards equal rights for
women and it looks causal
the more positively the country is
predisposed to female rights the more
likely they are to develop economically
and maybe that's because that indicates
that they're open to new ideas or
something like that or open to
transformation
so okay so that's one kind of equality
open up the playing field
so that everybody has a chance to
compete and cooperate and and land where
they will
but then the other kind of equality is
equality of outcome
so and that's often described as equity
in today's language and so
the ultimate equity utopia would be
take every job every conceivable kind of
job
and then stratify that by every
conceivable level of
authority within every job and then
ensure that every single category of
person
is represented in precise uh proportion
to their
to their prevalence in the population so
every job should be 50
women and 50 men and say 13 non-western
ethnic minority and
whatever that happens to be and then you
could break that down and so
and otherwise there's evidence of
systemic prejudice
okay now first thing to say about that
is that's impossible
and the reason it's impossible is
because there's no limit to the number
of ways that you can categorize people
into groups
so you know you you know about sex and
ethnicity and race maybe those are the
obvious ones but now you have gender and
then you have
ethnicity and you know and then there's
attractiveness and intelligence and
temperament and
and height and age and and socioeconomic
background and i mean
let's say there's 20 but there's a lot
more than that
there's no possible way that you could
ever
regulate a society so tightly that
every single one of those groups was
equally represented in every single one
of those occupations at
every single level of the hierarchy so
they want to concentrate on the
significant ones
men and women and race well yeah but
who's to say those are the significant
ones
that's the other thing it isn't even
obvious that they are because i would
say that like a more significant one is
cognitive ability
because that's a way bigger predictor of
long-term life success than sex or race
so i don't even think that we've
necessarily identified the canonical
groups we've just decided that gender
and race
are the maybe they're the most obvious
right but isn't there a problem is it
people
don't that what what they don't do is
they don't
take in in terms of cognitive ability
they don't get on a team
they don't get on like there's people
that are sexist
yeah but there's it's very rare that
someone is elitist in terms of their
cognitive ability
well hard to say joel i mean i think one
of the reasons though i shouldn't say
elitist prejudiced
is a better word i don't know i mean you
could be right but look i think one of
the reasons that
like if you here's something that's kind
of exciting makes sense now that i'm
thinking about it of course they are
it's well there's one thing that's quite
peculiar about the united states in that
regard
it's like most working-class people
let's say
are far more irritated with the
intellectual elite than they are with
the wealthy elite
and that's because they think they could
become wealthy and they could
but they don't think they could become
part of the intellectual elite and it
isn't obvious to me that the
intellectual elite
so those would be the liberal
left-leaning types that dominate the
media and academia
are particularly um positive
in their in their attitudes towards
the typical working-class person i think
they're prejudiced and elitist i do
believe that that's the case and i think
they're also
what would you call it patronizing and i
think that the typical
working-class person say who voted for
trump is very very sensitive to that
and so they're much more concerned with
the one percent who are the cognitive
elite than they are the one percent who
are the
economic elite because at least they
think that's a game they could play
so anyways it is not also because
there's caricatures right of the the one
percent of
the economic elite you just think of
people that are in these lofty positions
that are in control the financial
institutions but the one percent
of the intellectual elite you think of
in terms of like some of the more
preposterous things you're hearing out
of universities now
and safe spaces and oh yeah there's that
too
there's that too there's no well there's
no appreciation on the part of the
intellectual elite for the pathologies
of rational
of rationalism right i mean there's no
there's nothing stupider than a smart
person who went wrong
you know like you you can tank on i've
seen this in my clients you know
frequently like if i have a particularly
smart client who's particularly
disordered in their personality that
that's just
that's often just that's so difficult
it's almost unimaginable because there's
so
much rationalizing for example yeah
what is your approach to handling
something like that who's like
super intelligent but yet completely
their life is in disarray
well you know i'm i usually i usually
take a very practical approach like
you know we try to identify because i
start always in my therapy practice i
always start with behavioral principles
it's like okay well let's see if we can
identify
a few areas you know through negotiation
that are really causing you grief and
misery
you know like what's what's wrong with
your life as far as you're concerned
and so that often takes a lot of
discussion and then we might try to
figure out what's causing that
and that's often very difficult to
figure out too because it might be
geez it might be something physical you
know you might be sick in some way
because depression is
lots of depression is autoimmune related
and and anxiety can be a side effect of
all sorts of physiological disorders or
eating improperly or sleeping badly or
or not exercising
you know enough to to kind of keep
yourself regulated so you try to figure
out what's
what's causing it and then you try to
sketch out some possible solution that
we could both
test and then with the with the uh
with the more intelligent ones you know
often they can come up with all sorts of
reasons why none of this is going to
work
or or a thousand reasons why yeah well
usually a thousand reasons why none of
this is going to work
and that with people like that sometimes
it's useful to turn to their dreams if
if they dream because one of the things
that's cool about dreams is that even
though they're hard to interpret
they never lie and so sometimes you can
take someone who's hyper rational
they'll have a dream and they'll tell
you the dream
and then you can work through an
interpretation which is a tricky
business
and the dream will tell them something
and there's just no denying it it's like
well
it's a statement from nature so what are
you going to do you're going to pretend
that that's not the case
you know so so that's that's often
extremely useful
so so okay so well back to the equality
issue so okay so here's what's happened
so psychologists have and this is what's
putting a tail
not in the tail of the scandinavians
psychologists have come
to a pretty decent agreement about
standard personality models right so
there's extroversion neuroticism
agreeableness
openness and conscientiousness and they
look fairly stable cross-culturally
and that was all done by asking
thousands of people
hundreds and hundreds of questions and
then grouping them statistically
so it was a theoretical basically
took computational power and statistics
to to find out that these are
how traits group so
um inextroverted people are sociable and
happy and
neurotic people experience a fair bit of
negative emotion so that's the positive
and negative emotion dimensions
agreeable people are maternal and
disagreeable people are competitive
and there's a fair bit of male female
difference there conscientious people
are dutiful and industrious and orderly
and the open people are creative and so
those are your basic five dimensions
okay so that's been established and
everyone more or less agrees on it
now maybe there's seven dimensions and
we've got a
questionnaire that that that breaks the
five down into ten
that's called understand myself um
but but basically there's good there's
good
consensus consent consensus on the five
okay so now as soon as you have the five
basic traits you can ask some questions
like well do men and women differ
and so what you do is you just give the
questionnaire
you can either fill it out yourself or
have other people fill it out on your
behalf
so and it could be a teacher could be a
parent you know and that's all been done
and what you find is there are
systematic differences between men and
women
and the biggest differences are that
women experience more negative emotion
and that and that they're more agreeable
than men
so and that's borne out by the
psychiatric evidence because
higher levels of negative emotion are
manifested in depression and
anxiety and women are diagnosed with
higher levels of depression and anxiety
all around the world
and with agreeableness that's also borne
out by the
clinical literature in some sense the
medical literature sociomedical
literature
because disagreeable people are more
likely to be incarcerated
because it's the best predictor of being
incarcerated even though it's not a very
good predictor
and men are incarcerated at about a ten
to one rate compared to women and are
more likely to be antisocial and conduct
disordered
so the personality differences are
mirrored in the
socio-medical literature okay so that so
now so there are differences but then
there's a question
are those differences a consequence of
socialization or are they biological
and the answer to that is tricky because
how much something is social and how
much it is biological
actually depends on the social
circumstances
so well here's an example if you have a
society
where no one has enough to eat and
people are starving
then there's a huge cultural effect on
people's
intelligence let's say that's mediated
by economic factors
even though it's got a biological origin
right that's the starvation
so the relationship between biology and
culture is actually
partly culturally dependent so it makes
it complicated but in any case
here's how the scientists decided to
address this
they thought well why don't we
rank order countries by how egalitarian
their social policies are
which you can do with a fair degree of
reliability
you know you put the countries where
women are second-class citizens at the
bottom and you put the scandinavian
countries at the top you can get good
reliability across raiders
for how you'd rate those countries and
then look at the magnitude of the
differences between men and women
by the egalitarian social policies and
so then you'll find out
and here's the hypothesis if the
differences between men and women are
primary
primarily social then as cultures become
more egalitarian men and women will
become more alike
that's not what happened the opposite
happened
the the more egalitarian this society
and it turns out the richer the society
because that's also being discovered now
the more different men and women become
and so the differences are not huge so
with agreeableness for example
if you took the average man if you took
a typical man and a typical woman out of
the population just randomly
and you had to bet that the woman was
more aggressive than the man
you'd be wrong 60 percent of the time
so there's quite a bit of overlap right
because you'd be right 40 percent of the
time
but the problem is is that a lot of
selection takes place at the extremes
maybe you're only concerned about
disagreeable people when they become
violent and maybe it's only the one in
most disagreeable person who's violent
and they're all men
so you can have quite a bit of
similarity at
the average level and big differences at
the extremes
and the extremes is where people do
things like like uh
employment selection so the biggest
difference that's been discovered
between men and women
and this is the one that gets biggest in
the scandinavian countries is interest
men are more interested in things and
women are more interested in people
and it's a big difference it's one full
standard deviation and so what that
means is that
if you were a man you would have to be
more interested in people than 85
percent of men
to be as interested in people as the
50th percentile woman
and you'd have to be more interested in
things than 85 percent of women to be as
interested in things as the typical man
and what do you how do you define things
objective gadgets
okay gadgets gadgets things non
non-inanimate things cars car yeah yeah
tools yeah you know technology right
right stem
fields because the other thing that's
happened is that the more egalitarian
the society the fewer women go into the
stem
fields the fewer that's interesting yeah
okay so so now this unravels in a big
way
it's like this is a hugely uh
relevant issue politically because it
means that
you cannot have equality of opportunity
and equality of outcome at the same time
it's not possible because as you make
your society more egalitarian
and you open up the opportunity for
equality of outcome
you increase how different men and women
are are
and that changes their occupational
choice
so if men are more interested in things
which they are
by a substantial margin then way more of
them are going to be engineers
wouldn't that possibly support this idea
that an enforced
model of of of equality
would allow people to be themselves more
i mean this is almost what you're saying
well that's because that is that is the
optimistic viewpoint
well look it's so funny because the
swedish foreign minister told me to go
croc
climb back under the rock that i came
out from under when i was in scandinavia
because i was
describing this these this this science
i read that but i'm not exactly sure why
well she regards me as misogynist
because i think that there are
because i think because i've been
putting forward the evidence that there
are genuine differences between men and
women
but she should be held accountable for
that because that's just a flippant
thing to say
like you you should have especially in a
position of power like she's in
you should have a very specific argument
saying like
for a leader to have such a a base thing
to say such a a
crude dumb thing to say crawl back under
the rock that you came from well i
thought she was making a joke about
lobsters but i don't
think she was the lobsters going to
rocks i guess they do they're growing
cracks
yeah and the bigger lobsters have better
rocks that was another very interesting
thing in the gq thing where the woman
was uh
challenging you on your neural biology
your oh yeah
yes well hardly hardly any hardly any uh
uh
psychologists understand that serotonin
is associated with
hierarchies it's like a truism it's been
known for 30 years so
we can definitely get back to that but
i'm very curious about this because
this idea of uh enforced equality right
ensuring that there is such a high
emphasis
played or placed on equal equality that
you have the equal amount of men the
equal amount of women and the
opportunities are absolutely available
as much to women as they are today and
this is enforced yeah
this creates an environment where
there's less resistance
now in an environment where there's less
resistance
perhaps women don't feel as compelled to
say i'll show
you yeah that is what seems to happen
this is the
well here's an look here's an example so
there are fewer women mathematicians in
the in the higher echelons okay but
here's
something interesting about mathematical
ability first of all it's very rare
so that's the first thing to keep in
mind now it looks like if you look in
junior high
that give mathematically gifted men and
males and females are approximately as
common now there's a little bit of
debate about that because
there is some evidence that maybe at the
very upper extremes there's a male
advantage just like there's a male
disadvantage at the low end
because the male distribution for
intelligence might be flatter
and so that's the greater male
variability hypothesis
there's been papers putting that forward
that have been retracted as a
consequence of pressure from politically
correct people
even though greater male variability is
actually quite common in the animal
kingdom for a variety of reasons
men are more expendable that males are
more expendable in some ways
or you could say that males are more
likely to produ to
pursue high risk high return strategies
you can look at it either way and it's
certainly possible
in any case the men the males in junior
high who happen to be mathematically
gifted are less likely to
also be verbally gifted whereas that
doesn't seem to be the case for the
females
and so if you're a male math nerd then
math is a pretty logical pathway for you
because
you don't have as many other options
whereas if you're a female math nerd you
have other options because you're all
you're less likely you're more likely to
also be verbally gifted
and so that's enough to at least in
principle account for some of the reason
why there are fewer
women mathematicians than men
mathematicians they have other options
they have other options and there's lots
of complex there's lots of complex
reasons like this and so
we have this reflexive idea and this is
very much the case because this is like
the core idea among the feminist
neo-marxist types
is that if there's differences in
outcome that's
that's proof of prejudice and that's
support for the idea of the patriarchal
tyranny and that's like the core
axiom of the radical left is the
patriarchal tyranny as far as i'm
concerned that's
that's god for them the patriarchal
tyranny it's like well
if it turns out that many of these
differences in outcome between men and
women aren't a consequence of the
patriarchal tyranny in fact even get
bigger when you reduce the tyrannical
aspect of the patriarch and even the
patriarchal aspect to it
then it makes that theory not only
wrong but opposite of the truth which is
the worst kind of wrong
and so you know if men are more likely
to
pursue careers in the stem fields which
seems to be the case
under conditions of optimal freedom for
men and women then that's going to drive
income disparities because the stem
fields pay more
and they pay more partly because they're
scalable like it's really hard to scale
care for people you know like if you
work in a daycare you're going to care
for three infants
you're not going to care for 50 because
you can't it's not scalable
but if you're like a software designer
it's infinitely scalable and so
there's there's a much wider range of
possible
of possibility for generating much
larger
much larger income pools and much larger
pools of wealth
you know and men are also more likely to
work longer hours and if you work 10
percent longer hours you make 40 percent
more money there's a non-linear return
on
that's a good thing for everybody who's
listening to know if you have a job
you want to be the guy or the woman
who's working that extra 10
because the return on that is non-linear
so that's a really useful thing to know
men are more likely to work outside
they're more likely to work in dangerous
businesses they're more likely to
run full-time businesses rather than
part-time businesses
and they're more likely to move in
pursuit of their career goals
and that all contributes to differences
in and
and in in among uber drivers they're
they make seven percent more money
because they drive faster
so and so anyway that's not good though
well no but it's a high risk it's a high
risk high return issue
right i mean it's a pattern male 1 yeah
it's more risk there's more risk in it
so there's more return as long as you
don't get hurt
right and i think that's a pretty common
male pattern is there's more risk is
there's more return as long as you don't
get hurt the problem seems to be
when discussing these things in any way
uh romanticizing or uh glorifying
male behavior or putting any emphasis
whatsoever
on there being a a positive aspect to a
lot of the things that we think of as
being negative
like aggression or ambition or or
yeah or competition yeah yeah well the
competition amongst men is fine
competition with men against women is
often thought of as cruel
yeah well that yes well and and there's
a certain amount of reason for that as
well because
obviously physical competition is
it's easy for that to border on cruel
this is why we were
we were talking before the show that
instead of calling people
men and women when referring to like
because there's there's this
very disturbing in my opinion trend of
transgender women
entering into these competitions now
with women who are biologically female
yeah and dominating them yeah and that
instead of calling people men and women
let's dispense with you yeah you can be
a man or a woman
yeah you can be a man or woman that's
your choice and you can change it
whenever
you want so you're a man or a woman that
and that's your choice
but we're going to have a new rule which
is that if you have
an x y chromosome so you're an x y
person or an x x person
then if you're an x x pers xy person you
don't get to engage in physical combat
with an xy person
yes men or one xxx doesn't matter yes
yeah how would that be if you're xy you
can't
engage in physical combat with x that's
right xyz cannot hit x
x's how's that and maybe they can't um
run in running contests against them and
maybe they can't play tennis against
them not within
and maybe that's just reasonable right
it is reasonable yes it is certainly
it is reasonable but if you you talk
about that especially someone like you
who was you were against this bill that
was going to enforce
these pronouns and the com compelling
the use of these pronouns
that you're thought to be a transphobic
person yeah because you feel like
there maybe should be some rational
discussion about the physical
limitations of certain body structures
because that's what it is
if you're talking about my field of
business you're talking about combat
sports
right i've been involved in combat
sports my whole life and there is a
difference
and it's not to say that females aren't
aren't competent and i mean i had miriam
nakamoto on yesterday
she's a good friend of mine she's an
eight-time world muay thai champion and
she's a monster
but she doesn't fight against men and
she shouldn't fight against men although
she probably could beat a bunch of them
right it's not she shouldn't have to and
she's tough women a tough woman can beat
a variety of men yes but a really tough
man can beat all women
yes right so that's the problem that's
the reality yes and that is definitely
this is reality
you know and people don't like to hear
these things and they don't they
they want to pretend that you can even
out the playing field with hormones
no you can even at a little there's
certain things like i've always said you
if you gave brock lesnar a sex change
and put him in a dress
he's going to run through every woman
that's ever lived in the history of
women
there's not a single woman that's going
to be able to deal with that bone
structure
and that that mind that that guy has had
with testosterone pumping through it for
39 years it's just you just
it's just it's just preposterous that we
even have to have to have the discussion
it's so it's so absolutely ridiculous
it's the one thing that i was attacked
on more than anything
in my entire life is saying that i think
it's ridiculous to have a trans woman
compete against women and mixed martial
arts
i was like you want to have them do it
in chess you want to have them do it in
something that's non-physical
sure you want them to be a woman yes
okay you want them to be recognized as a
woman you're sure but as soon as you're
compelling people like here's one that's
going up lately if you
don't want to date a trans woman
then you're some sort of a bigot that if
you're a man
even if you want a family you know you
remember in in
in uh brave new world in huxley's book
it was considered immoral to reject
anyone's sexual advances because it was
prejudicial
oh yes and the thing is it is
that's the thing now but but to see so
that makes the question even more
interesting because the
the question is at what point do you
have the right to your prejudices
right and what one of the things that we
seem to cling to
um and i would say rightly is that
we're allowed to be prejudiced when it
comes to who
we interact with sexually and then and
who we choose as friends
and that's right that's the right to
association and you know you say but
only up to a certain point well that's
this is the because this this new
logic is kind of leaking into sexual
preferences now
like if you have a problem with someone
being overweight
yeah then you're you're a sizes or
something yeah like what is that
well the thing is is that you can't have
preferences without having prejudices of
course
right and so that's a big that's a big
issue so what does that mean you don't
get to have any preferences
how's that gonna work out in terms of
like what you like to eat or what kind
of films you enjoy or what kind of books
you read you're allowed to have these
preferences but when it comes to what
you're sexually attracted to
there's new emphasis now trying to draw
that line
and and say like but it's preposterous
people that are pushing this and
almost everybody's pushing back but i
find it interesting well it's a logical
it's a logical conclusion to all these
other things that have been happening
because
that is where the rubber hits the road
it's like you know when when i
when i well i've seen this in in debates
that i've had publicly where people
you know talk about prejudice and i've
pointed out to them that they have
prejudicial attitudes with regards to
their sexual preferences because they
don't just sleep with anyone who asks
them
right so it's like well how is that not
a prejudice
well of course it's a prejudice well
then the question is under what
circumstances are prejudices justifiable
and that's a conversation we don't like
to have because we believe that there
are no circumstances whatsoever under
which prejudices are
are acceptable there's a big difference
between prejudices and discrimination i
think those two get conflated
yes there is a big difference between
prejudice and discrimination
right and hopefully discrimination has
to do with
uh setting your standards in
relationship to the task at hand
yes right that that's what you'd hoped
for that that's the appropriate form
right of discrimination right that's
that's like intelligence
sure everything everything isn't the
same about everything all the time
so you discriminate you rank order
things and you need to rank order them
even to pursue things that are valuable
this is one of the problems with the
people who are so anti-hierarchy like
the
like the radical leftists well there
shouldn't be hierarchies it's like okay
then why do something
well that that argument is so foolhardy
that
it's it's difficult to take seriously
but you do have to engage in it and i
think when you engage in it
it's really fascinating to watch uh
because
there's it's like you're playing a game
of chess with someone only has a couple
of pieces
they have this strong move that they do
but you've got all these other pieces
and you're like well
let's just keep this game going until
this comes this logical conclusion which
is checkmate there's
there's hierarchies all throughout
nature it doesn't mean people should
suppress people it doesn't mean people
shouldn't have rights it doesn't mean
people should
enforce themselves or force themselves
on other folks that's not what it means
it also doesn't mean that the
hierarchies especially if they're human
hierarchies
well or or or that they're only that's
right not that they're good necessarily
or that they're predicated on power like
one of the most pathological elements of
the postmodern types especially people
like foucault
is their insistence that all
hierarchical structures are predicated
on
power and that there's nothing other
than power and that's completely
preposterous
i mean i use examples of plumbers in my
lectures
more recently because it's rather
comical it's like well
on what basis do you hire a plumber so
imagine that there's a hierarchy of
plumbers ranging from very successful to
very unsuccessful
okay and you say well what makes
plumbers successful well
the power theory would would imply that
there are roving bands of
mafioso plumbers who like come pounding
on your door at three in the morning and
tell you that if
you don't get their particular posse to
fix your pipes leaking or not that
they're gonna come and burn down your
house of course that's completely
it's completely absurd when you
go to hire someone like a plumber well
the first thing you want to know is
reputation can they actually fix a pipe
because you actually want your pipe
fixed and then you want to know well do
they deal with you fairly and
part of what's tangled up in that in all
likelihood is do they deal with their
employees fairly because that's going to
make their business function properly
and
so the hierarchy of plumbers which is
part of the patriarchal tyranny
is almost entirely predicated on
competence and
almost every enterprise in the west is
like that
because i keep wondering well where the
hell is this patriarchal tyranny
like is it massage therapists is it
nurses like
most nurses are female if you get
females organized into a hierarchy which
you do in nursing
is that all of a sudden is that part of
the patriarchal tyranny
or is it the fact that now all those
people are women does that mean it's no
longer
well it's still a hierarchy is it no
longer a tyranny
is it no longer patriarchal like is it
patriarchal only because there's men in
it or is it patriarchal because it's a
hierarchy
all this stuff is so incoherent that it
just all you have to do is think about
it and
and that hasn't been done to any great
degree and it just dissolves in your
hands yes that's what i'm saying is that
if you're entering into a job straight
out of college you leave university and
now you're entering into you know
your first year in the workplace it's
it's just a natural fact
of life that there's going to be people
that are further ahead in this race than
you
yeah because they're better at what they
do some of them because they have more
experience
some of them are more crooked and sneaky
too possible as well because
but it's the it's the agreeing everyone
agreeing that this is a game
yeah this is some sort of a competition
yes and you're going to have hierarchies
in competitions you're going to have
people who win
you're going to have people who do
better yes you know no matter what
so that's the fundamental issue as soon
as you so we could look at it this way
as soon as you let's assume people have
problems
everybody can agree on that and then we
could assume that people would like
solutions to those problems so we could
agree on that
then we could say well then if you
implement a solution socially
so with other people then you're going
to cooperate and compete in relationship
to the solution
and that's instantly going to produce a
hierarchy because no matter what the
problem is
some people are going to be better at
solving it than others and then if you
have any sense you put the people who
are good at solving it at the forefront
because then they solve it faster and
cheaper and better and then everybody
benefits but then you get a hierarchy
right the people who solve those
problems get
financial incentive to solve those
problems yes and they do that
and they do that because the rest of us
are greedy and desperate it's like
you know we want the people who are good
at solving the problems to
keep solving them and so what we're
trying to do is to reward them so that
they'll keep doing it even if it's
difficult
to give them some status extraordinarily
if necessary yes yes
when you look at the people that are the
the head of giant industry
the the ceos of super successful
companies they're the ones who have the
giant yachts and the big houses and this
is the incentive for people to try
to get to that position and the idea
that there's no incentive and
there should be no incentive but yet
you're still going to have all this
innovation is ridiculous it's not how it
works
it's not a human being's work if human
beings are going to work really hard
there has to be some sort of a reward
and it can't be an equal reward yes and
then then what you could say like
so okay so the right that that would be
roughly speaking a conservative position
and then you can take a left-wing
position that's reasonable and you can
say yes
there are hierarchies but we have to
stay awake because they can
degenerate into power hungry tyrannies
so that it's no longer
competence it's it's political
machination and game playing
and tyranny that that produce the
positional the positional
differentiation
so we've got to stay awake to that and
so we've got to criticize the
hierarchies
not the fact of hierarchy but the
structure of hierarchy so they stay
honest
and then we also have to be careful
because when you do set up a hierarchy
then a lot of people collect at the
bottom that's the necessary consequence
of a few people collecting at the top
and so then you have to be concerned
about those people at the bottom and so
there's a variety of things that you
would do
to express that concern is one you might
want to have a lot of hierarchies
so that people have different talents
could play different games
and a complex society is pretty good at
that but you're still going to have
people who stack up at the bottom of all
hierarchies right those are going to be
people who are sick
mentally and physically and maybe people
who are cognitively impaired or
you know or who've experienced some kind
of catastrophe in their life
and then you you want to set up your
system so that those people
don't suffer unduly partly because
that's bad and partly because that
destabilizes your whole society
and so you could say well that's the
left's place is to speak for the
speak on behalf of the unjustly
dispossessed
and the right's position is to stabilize
and
maintain functional hierarchies and
encourage competition and encourage
competition that's of benefit to the
whole yes
and and to the individuals within the
competition and then the political
dialogue is a continual
discussion between the left and the
right saying well you know this
hierarchy is getting a little too steep
and a little too rigid
and and and well and that's for me
that's also
the the fundamental reason for the
necessity of free speech
is because that's the only way to
discuss this it is the only it's the
only way of working it out
and it is the case you nee you're going
to produce hierarchies if you're going
to pursue things of value socially
you're going to
produce hierarchies and they're
necessary and there's also
i have a giant issue with the concept
that these things are mutually exclusive
that you can't have
competition and also have a a a good
social environment
i think that's a preposterous idea i
mean one of the things i really like
about the
psychologist jean piaget who's i would
say the world's foremost expert on games
is that he did a very careful analysis
of say competitive games
okay so let's take hockey or soccer it
doesn't matter same example okay
you say well because people now they
they have kids play these games and
don't keep score
which of course the kids keep score
because they're not stupid like the
adults but
you know while we can't have it be
competitive okay so let's take it apart
it's like
well is hockey a competitive game or a
cooperative game
okay well so first of all everyone's
trying to do the same thing
that's cooperative it's not like half
the people are playing chess and another
you know a third of them brought a
basketball and two of them are boxing
and
well sometimes they do in hockey boxing
in a quarter but
everyone's trying to do the same thing
so that's cooperative
okay everyone plays their position
that's cooperative
they all follow the same rules that's
cooperative
right so so there's competition
but it's nested inside a fundamental
structure of cooperation
and the cooperation is the cooperation
is the basis
of the game itself let's all arbitrarily
agree that it's important to put this
black disc in the net
which is to get your aim right and then
let's cooperate within our teams to do
that
because we're going to pass and we're
going to we're going to pass to each
other and we're also going to work so
that each of us is a good player but so
that we all work
for the betterment of our team because
we want to win games across
multiple games so that's also
cooperative and then
you want to interact with your your
enemies let's say the other team
in a way that's indicative of good
sportsmanship so that the entire league
can flourish and to think of that as
competitive is
absolutely it's so um
there's no other way of describing it
than stupid
that's what it is it's a it's a it's an
ignorant unidimensional analysis
it's put forward by someone who's
reflexively opposed to anything that
smacks of competition and who isn't
thinking it through at all
they're denying the benefits of
competition and the fact that they reap
those very benefits of competition by
enjoying the products that are created
by these corporations yes
well it's very hypocritical and well
well that's for sure that's called a
performative contradiction it's like
well i'd like to i like to complain
about left-wing issues on my iphone
right
exactly you know it's like well yeah
fair enough but you know you should have
a little gratitude for the fact that
you've got your iphone to complain about
and those and those organizations those
uh
corporations are unbelievably
competitive and they fall apart almost
instantly when that competition starts
start stops being a
an issue because then there's no
constraint on the behavior of the
behavior of the system so
yes and you know the issue with men i
think with young men
and this is one of the things i've been
trying to address is that if your
fundamental
presupposition is that our culture is a
patriarchal tyranny which is an
appalling presupposition
along with the idea that the best way of
looking at history is that it
it was the oppression the continual
oppression of women by
men which is also something that i
regard as absolutely reprehensible
doctrine
then okay so it's a patriarchal tyranny
but but that
in their defense that did exist there
has been continual oppression of women
it's just not the only thing that's
happened
well there's been women that have been
revered there's been women that have
been celebrated
there's been women that have
accomplished great things but there's
been a lot of oppression
so if they concentrate primarily on that
oppression and that's their main point
of study
and that's the thing they want to talk
about all the time they kind of have a
point
in the fact that if you're looking at
all the events that have ever taken
place
there's a significant number of them
that have been women being oppressed
yeah but i don't know if
i don't know if there's more women
who've been oppressed than men who've
been oppressed that's a very good point
so i would say that the entire history
of
i mean you look at it this way is that
we oppress ourselves
personally with our own malevolence and
stupidity and then we're all oppressed
by the kind of the crushing hand of
the social world that molds us in one
way and not in another
and then of course nature is doing her
best all the time
to give birth to us but also to kill us
and take us out
and so there's this endless like
there's this endless what would you call
it vulnerability that characterizes our
existence psychologically and socially
and naturally and
and i would say 150 years ago that was
even more intense than it was now you
know because the typical person in the
west lived on less than a dollar a day
before 1895.
and so the way i think that we should
view the history of the world is that
men and women
labored under virtually impossible
conditions for the entire bulk of human
evolution
and they did their best to cooperate and
to compete but to cooperate
so that they had some modicum
some possibility of a modicum of
security and satisfaction
and that that's the right framework and
then within that of course there's power
games that are played by people who are
corrupt
yeah within that there's horrible events
of course things have taken place but
there's
there's a massive amount of hypocritical
thinking when you are
criticizing the actions of so many
people and and
talking about how many people are
complicit in these things while you're
carrying around a phone that's made by
someone who gets a dollar a day
i was talking to a journalist in
slovenia
who is a lefty and and not a very
sophisticated one
and she was talking about the one
percent and i said well do you know that
if you make more than 32 000
a year that you're part of the one
percent she said well what do you mean i
said well that's the worldwide statistic
it's like so you're part of the one
percent well she didn't
first of all she said well i don't
believe that statistic and i thought
well that's fine you can go look it up
yourself but
what was so interesting was that for her
that characterization the one percent
victimizers
was only relevant within the confines of
her national border
right right as soon as i said well no
it's all you have to do is expand that
out a little bit and you're the problem
and not the solution
then that was that was completely
untenable for her exactly she couldn't
include herself in the population of
victimizers even though
you know she lives in a western country
and she's a well-paid journalist and
she's lives a very privileged life
so to speak by historical and world
standards to someone living in the congo
or something
or or anybody living anywhere in the
entire history of
the human race right yeah for sure if
you make thirty four thousand dollars
today
you absolutely are in the top one
percent of everybody who's ever
definitely well of course
of course yes yes definitely especially
given what you can buy with it
the only reason to deny that is because
it doesn't fit what you've come into the
argument with
it doesn't it doesn't fit your pre the
the priest
predisposed notion that you have the
your idea that you're it's so rigid this
idea that
you are not one of the ones that's just
that's right that's exactly
carrying that iphone with that laptop
and all these different things that you
enjoy that are created by these
corporations that you you support them
financially but yet they're the ones
that are destroying this earth
these are the ones that you're rallying
against these are the ones you hate
against yeah well the victim victimizer
narrative only works if you assume that
you're a victim
right and as soon as you assume that
you're a victimizer well then it's not
so much fun
one of the things i wrote the um forward
for the new version of
of solzhenitsyn's gulag archipelago the
abridged version it came out november
1st and
i was trying to figure out why the
russian revolution went wrong so rapidly
because it went wrong right from the
beginning and
they they sold itself quotes this guy
named i think his name was walter lazis
if i remember correctly i got the latsis
part right anyways and he said
when you're interrogating a member of
the bourgeoisie
um to decide whether they you know
whether they
constitute an enemy of the state you
don't give any credibility to such
niceties as individual guilt or
innocence all you care about is their
group and their
background and their economic status and
if they're in the wrong group
the bourgeoisie then that's it that's
the end of them
and solzhenitsyn comments not just the
end of them but the end of their
children and their grandchildren as well
and latsis was eventually executed by
stalin somebody wrote me and just told
me that after i wrote the forward
but one of the things i figured out was
this and this is really worth thinking
about man
so the intersectional claim is that
you know each person has more than one
group identity so
fundamentally if you're going to
calculate their victim status then you
have to calculate it across
all the different groups that they might
be victims in and so
you know maybe uh oh who knows a native
american is one form of victim in this
line of thinking but a native american
victim is
a female is is like twice the victim or
however you would calculate that
mathematically it's like
okay and maybe you have maybe you can be
put into six different groups
we already talked about that a little
bit but here's the bloody rub
if i put you in six groups in one of
those groups you're a victimizer
you can bloody well bet on it and then
here's the next
rule if you're a victimizer among any
possible dimension of analysis
then it's the gulag for you and so
that's the fundamental danger of that
group identity victimizer victim
narrative is that you fragment your
identity in multiple dimensions
you'll find out that you're a victimizer
and then everyone then everyone's a
criminal and then everyone's guilty
that's exactly what happened in russia
and then you think well wait a minute
there are a bunch of people who are
really compassionate about the poor
it's like let's say just for the sake of
argument that at the beginning of the
russian revolution
the 20 of the communists were really
concerned about the poor
maybe we could say 50 just to be
arbitrary about it
the other 50 were jealous and resentful
about anyone who anything more than they
did
all right now that you put those two
groups head to head in a battle for four
years and see who's standing at the end
even if you are one of those utopians
who actually cares for the
dispossessed when the revolution comes
you can bloody well be sure that your
head's going to be first on the chopping
block
because the people who are motivated by
hate are going to be a lot more vicious
in their attempts to eradicate than
you're going to be
what would you call it effective in your
in your attempts to save
that whole game that whole identity
politics game that is dangerous beyond
belief
and it's it's predicated fundamentally
on resentment and
and the desire to devolve people back
into a tribal antagonism
i think it's so important that you talk
about it this way and i think it's
really interesting when i see the
resistance to you talking about it this
way and how
many people are unwilling to look at it
as this
multi-level historical sort of record
you could look and see how this played
out and you can look and see
what's going on right now with these
control games that people are playing
socially
and that they are enforcing certain
types of behavior in certain ways of
thinking
and then trying to rein in earnings and
and
rally against capitalism and support
communism and socialism
and doing so in this sort of weird
trendy way without understanding the
full scope
of the historical implications when it's
been tried in the past
that it's not as simple as like you know
uh you know
you got this ann ryan thing doing you're
looking at this world of
you know uh capitalism against socialism
it's good people
who care about folks versus people who
are ruthless
it's not that well that isn't even how
capitalism doesn't even work like that
you know that managers are more stressed
by the people they manage than the
people they manage are stressed by their
managers
i mean then think about it right just
all you have to think about that for a
minute
it's like you're an employee and you
have a manager and the manager is a bit
of a jerk let's say
but there's 20 of you right so there's
like you're kind of 120th oppressed by
the manager
but now you're the manager and you're
managing 20 people and you're
responsible for them and we're assuming
that you're not a psychopath
and you're probably not because you
probably wouldn't have been able to get
to be a manager if you're a psychopath
because
psychopaths generally aren't very
successful and they have to keep moving
as people figure out who they are
so the idea that like psychopathic power
is a good route to power in a
functioning organization it's a stupid
theory
there are some organizations that are
pathological enough so that works but
they don't last very long either
so you're the manager and you're a
decent human being and you've got 20
people who are dependent on you and at
least two of those people are real
trouble
like they're serious trouble and they're
they're they're
you're concerned all the time and so you
see this as
and as people move up the corporate
hierarchies you think well they have
more and more
power it's like yeah but not really
they have more and more responsibility
and their behavior is actually monitored
with increasing severity it's like
you're
quite constrained in most high-level
positions of authority in complex
organizations like you have to behave
pretty damn carefully or you're going to
get yourself in trouble very very
quickly
well certainly today i think that that
wasn't necessarily the case a decade ago
or two decades ago
it was less the case yes less the case
today it's far easier to get called out
on things
but even so like you know even even 20
years ago like if you didn't treat your
customers properly
you know in and carefully reciprocally
in long-term relationships you're going
to be a failure
yeah and you know in in in any
corporation that that produces anything
of any value i mean the production is
one thing so you have to be competent at
the production
but you have to be in constant
communication with your
with your buyers and foster those
relationships personally because there's
intense competition and
if those personal relationships aren't
of high quality then
your business fails and one of the
things i really learned because i spent
a
lot of time with business people as well
as academics is that
business people do a tremendous amount
of socialization compared to academics
like academics can judge each other's
work more or less on the basis of its
scientific merit
and so they don't have to establish
personal relationships to the same
degree
but business people are always wondering
well can i trust you can we enter into a
reciprocal relationship that's going to
be of mutual benefit over the long run
and so they're testing people out
socially all the time and if you're not
capable of
reciprocating honestly over some decade
say
then you're going to screw things up in
an absolutely horrible way
it's one of the reasons why they like to
use golf as a matter yes exactly that's
exactly right there's two things one you
get to see how someone handles
competition yeah you get to see if they
cheat yeah because people do cheat and
golf you know it's an interesting story
a good friend of mine
his uh his dad was
playing golf with this man and uh his
wife was there as well
and the wife saw the dad move the or saw
this man that he was playing
golf with move the ball and she said do
not go into business with this man
do not trust this man he's a cheater he
cheated at golf
and he thought it was not that big a
deal it's like it's just a game of golf
he's like no this is a big deal
turns out the guy was a [ __ ] criminal
just took a while to find out i mean he
wound up doing a lot of other things
that
how you do some things is oftentimes how
you do everything yeah well that's why
people are so
um interested in games yes you know
because
a person really is well games this is
again why i'm such an admirer of piaget
because he knew very well that
game is a microcosm of reality yeah
that's why we like i mean you have to
have an explanation for why people like
games yeah you know and i've been
talking about this a lot in my lectures
too is you think well
you know any game like if any
competitive game
soccer is a good example it's basically
a hunting game
okay because you're you're firing a
projectile at a target
okay so the target's the goal and the
projectile's the ball but it doesn't
matter
is that so you have it you have teams
that are
figuring out how to hunt properly then
you think well
to hunt properly you have to put the
ball in the net as many
times as you possibly can so and so you
organize yourself in a hierarchy to
facilitate that
but then that's that's not the whole
story because you tell your kids
it doesn't matter whether you win or
lose it matters how you play the game
and the kids all freaked out about that
because he doesn't know what you mean
and he says well what do you mean dad
i'm trying supposed to try to win and
you say i don't know what i mean but
it's it's still true but here's what you
mean
is that if you're in a league you're not
trying to win the soccer game
you're trying to win the soccer
championship and to win the championship
you have to win a whole bunch of games
and the rules to win a whole bunch of
games aren't the same as the rules to
win one game
you know like you could go flat out as
the prima donna and bend and bend the
rules and cut corners and
exhaust everyone and win the game and
then lose the next three because that's
a stupid medium to long-term strategy
or you could be like the superstar and
hog the ball all the time and never give
your teammates a chance to develop but
then you're injured and your team is out
so that's a stupid strategy too so you
think well
what you have to do to win the
championship is that you have to
organize your team so that the best
players lead
but that everybody gets developed and
that you play
the medium to long-term game in a fair
way in a fair and decent way
okay and so you think well that's how
you win a championship i talked to a
coach a while back and he said one of
the things he did to select
athletes was to watch what happened when
they scored a goal
and if they were celebrating on their
own you know in sort of an egotistical
way
then that wasn't such a good sign but if
they scored a goal or a touchdown or
whatever it was and their
entire team came in and mobbed them and
then like lifted them up on their
shoulders and they thought that guy
is an athlete because not only can he
put the
goal put the ball in the net but he does
it in a way that benefits the entire
team
and that's the person you want around
for the long run and so then the goal
isn't just to put the ball in the goal
the goal is to put the ball in the goal
the the largest number of times while
simultaneously benefiting as many as
your of your fellow players as you can
well although i think that's a great
strategy i don't think that's
necessarily the meaning of it doesn't
matter if you win or lose it's how you
play the game
i think what i don't think people think
of it in terms of like a long-term
strategy for championship leagues i
think when they're saying
it doesn't matter whether you win or
lose it's how you play the game
meaning don't cheat yeah do your best
yeah and learn right but i think
that's right well learn how to handle
failure right learn how to handle
victory
we'll also learn from the experience
itself like if you make a mistake
and you you're trying your hardest but
you make an error
because someone has a counter to that
yeah then you learn from that yeah
that's how you play the game
right so stupidly and you don't think
and you win just because you got lucky
that's not as good
as playing intelligently and expanding
your skills and losing
yes because the other people are
superior and then you learn from the
fact that they figured out a way to
have solutions to all the problems that
you present yes okay so so one of the
things that you're pointing out is that
while you're playing
you want to be expanding your range of
skills so that you get better at playing
the next game
but then you think well even the soccer
championship isn't the whole game
right because your life is a whole
series of games of of
of championships of different titles the
idea is that championships will come if
you continue to excel
and get excellent yes and also if people
invite you to play
yes so there's both so those are the two
things so
that's the goal right the goal isn't to
put the ball in the net
the goal is to get excellent and to be
invited to play
and the mechanism is that you put the
ball in the goal and that makes sense
see that helps explain why people find
competitive sports so unbelievably
compelling because you can be cynical
about it you can say well look there's
50 000 people there watching
you know somebody kick a uh a spheroid
object into a net who the hell cares
like and but but that's not the issue
what you're what you are in fact doing
is you're going there to watch people
develop expertise and to learn to
play reciprocally in a noble and ethical
manner
and all of that sport when it's done
properly is a
direct physical incarnation of that
ethic
and so it's not surprising that that's
why people get so excited when they see
an athlete do something imagine the best
thing that you can see at a sports event
is
someone who does something purely in the
spirit of fair play and
in a manner that's unbelievably
excellent
wayne gretzky was very good at that
right because he was an excellent
excellent sportsman and also
unbelievably skilled and so people loved
him and that's that's perfect because he
was he was
a player who played the game like it was
more important to play it properly than
to win
and he was on the top of his game at the
same time right and that's what you want
to be in light didn't cut corners
that's right there's no cutting corners
yeah and so that's very cool and you see
a very high order ethic emerge out of
that
you want to be the kind of player that
everybody i kind of wrote about that in
12 rules for life when
you know because part of my advice in
rule 5 was not to let your kids do
anything that makes you dislike them
and that's part of the idea there is
that you know
if you're really on the side of your
children you help them develop
in a manner that makes them eminently
desirable to other children and capable
of interacting properly with adults
because then the whole world opens up to
them
that's a really and then you do that the
thing that's cool about that too is that
this is what makes the postmodern and
the marxist type so wrong is that
your best strategy for success in life
isn't the exercise of raw power
it's a really counterproductive strategy
doesn't even work very well for advanced
animals
your best strategy is skill and
reciprocity
so when there's a real high order ethic
in that that has nothing to do so the
idea that our hierarchies are predicated
on power and they're corrupt because of
that and the whole world is a
battleground between
hierarchies of you know different power
hierarchies and it's winner take all
and you know the devil take the hindmost
that's just that's completely
inappropriate psychologically there's a
a real situation where
you very rarely find people who excel
at competition and who have benefited
from competition who are against
competition
and you very rarely find people who have
no skill and competition at all and who
have never engaged and have shied away
from
their whole life that support it and and
and believe that it's an important part
of our culture
i think people want they want to believe
and they want to support things that
reinforce their idea of how they're
living their life correctly
and if if they shy away from competition
if it makes them nervous if they've
never excelled at it if it doesn't feel
right to them
if it makes them uncomfortable they want
to feel like there's some better way
and this is one of the things that leads
young sensitive
kind compassionate people towards
socialism and this concept that
capitalism and
any form of competition at all
ultimately is ultimately is going to
lead to
a few people hogging up all the wealth
and dominating all the people
well the other thing that's kind of sad
about that is that no matter what system
you set
up that's the outcome yeah you know like
if you look at
the pareto distribution so if that's the
distribution of wealth
you'll find that in every society that
we know of whether it's capitalist or
socialist or communist
for that matter a small proportion of
the people
have a disproportionate amount of the
resources
so so you so the other thing that i've
been trying to explain in my lectures
is that if you were really concerned
about the dispossessed and the poor you
wouldn't
put hierarchical dispossession at the
feet of capitalism
because it's a way worse problem than
that you know because the marxist types
they think well if we didn't have
capitalism
there wouldn't be hierarchies and there
wouldn't be dispossession and that's
complete bloody rubbish
because the problem of hierarchy and the
problem of dispossession is way deeper
than the problem of capitalism
so like if you look at neolithic grave
sites way before there was capitalism
you see that a small number of people
are buried with all the gold
so the the the fact of of
dis dis unequal distribution of
resources that's as old as
that's that's as old as hierarchies are
old it's unbelievably old
and so for the leftists to take an
anti-capitalist position and assume that
that's going to be of benefit to the
dispossessed is
an idea that's at least 145 years out of
date as far as i'm concerned
but we do want to discourage tyranny we
do want to keep
keep that we do want to keep someone
from accumulating so much wealth that
they
dominate the world and have a
disproportionate effect on culture
and and do things that are detrimental
that could be in fact detrimental for
decades and decades
to come i mean look to this day well
that's why you have a balance of powers
in the united states too
because yeah well the thing is it's not
the case
it should like the fact that you can't
characterize the west as a patriarchal
tyranny
doesn't mean that hierarchies don't
become tyrannical
sometimes they do and yeah and we have
to be alert to that and that's been
known for a very long time so is it fair
to say that the west
has some aspects of a hierarchy
hierarchical tyranny of course of course
and that's i would say that's a
mythological truism
so like the way that that society is
represented
in our deep narrative structures is
always twofold there's a wise king and a
tyrannical king
and they're pitted against each other
and your job is to
amplify the wise king and keep the
tyrant under control that's the evil
advisor to the king you know like scar
in the lion king yeah
right so he there's always this shadowy
figure in the background
that's malevolent and psychopathic and
power obsessed
that's attempting to take over the
hierarchy by by ill-gotten
means that and that that's that's that's
evil itself in some sense it's the
archetype of evil and so
that has to be taken into consideration
but
the problem with the viewpoint that's so
prevalent in our society right now is
that
that's the patriarchal tyranny viewpoint
is that it's only the evil king
and then that's particularly hard on
young men because if you believe that
all of our hierarchies are predicated on
nothing but arbitrary power
and then that's a natural consequence of
masculinity
then whenever you see anyone who's
masculine manifest anything that's
associated with
competence or confidence or or or or
um or let's say competitiveness or
or you know heaven forbid aggression
then you immediately assume that that's
nothing but a manifestation of
tyrannical power
and that you discourage it or or or you
certainly fail to encourage it
and i think that that's a dreadful
mistake because that all that
masculine energy whether that's
characteristic of women or men because
women can certainly manifest that
that's something that should be
integrated and celebrated and the way
you do that
that's partly why mechanisms like
competitive sports are so necessary is
that you want to take
um kids let's say boys the more
competitive and aggressive boys just for
this example
you want to take them and you want to
socialize them intensely
so that they take that aggressive
competitive impulse
and they're capable of manifesting it
inside a social structure like a game
so that it's of benefit to everyone and
and you can do that
it's not a problem you know you teach an
aggressive kid that
it's beneath his dignity to
uh bully someone weaker so you can
attach that right to the competitiveness
it's like you're a loser you bully
someone
weaker than you you're a loser that's
pathetic
yes it's like it it it speaks right to
that competitive
drive says oh i don't want to be a loser
of martial arts are so critical
i mean that's one of the major tenets of
martial arts you know this is a it is a
huge part of what's taught in
traditional martial arts academies
because there's a very clear way of
behaving
and you're you're never supposed to do
anything remotely like bullying right
right and you're supposed to have
because it's misuse of your power
exactly and you're supposed to have
extreme reverence for the people who
taught you
i mean your master you literally call
them a master right
you know in all almost all martial arts
right and so that's another well so
that's another thing that's really in
that's really interesting about a
functional hierarchy is like
because the the leftist critics look at
a hierarchy and they think
every position is up looking down right
right but what you're saying what you're
pointing out is no in a functional
hierarchy
there's plenty of respect going up
right so it's not only it's not just
power it's like it's power it's
it's it's authority and subordination at
the same time
voluntary subordination because you
should be
um you should be properly subordinate to
the people who are better at what you're
doing
yes and in a functional organization
that happens naturally and the other
thing that happens too and the radical
leftists never take this into account as
far as i'm concerned is that
one of the things i've learned about
people who've run successful
organizations
whether they're academic or business um
is that they really love mentoring young
people
it's a it's an intrinsic pleasure
because you know you think well it's
in for the evil capitalist it's it's
it's winner take all and and
and to hell with everyone else and
that's an unbelievably cynical view of
human nature it
only really applies to people who are
genuinely psychopathic and they're very
rare
and so most of the people i know that
have been hyper successful
are absolutely thrilled if they can find
a young person and they don't care
generally speaking about sex or creed or
color or any of that crap
they care about competence they want to
find a competent young person who's got
a lot of possibility
and then open up all sorts of doors of
opportunity for them and to see
how they can help them develop and if
they can do that with 20 or 30 people
then
like my graduates or my graduate
supervisor
had his uh he's getting old and he had
his retirement party about two years ago
and about 30 of the people that he
trained
in to becoming scientists came to his
party and they
talked non-stop about the beneficial
effect that
that he had on their life you know he
found a lot of them were
you know they were young and smart but
didn't really all that
properly oriented in the world and he
picked them out and gave them
opportunities and he certainly did this
for me has opened all sorts of doors for
me
and that was a huge source of pleasure
in his life i think maybe the primary
source he had a family as well
and obviously his family was of primary
importance but
in his professional career it wasn't
his name on papers and his you know his
his name in the market it was all these
young people whose careers he could
foster
never-ending source of satisfaction yeah
i think that's a critical aspect of
being a successful person
that you have to realize that there's a
there's a great personal benefit in
helping other people
and that you feel this this is not just
like something that looks good on paper
when you can show some young person
who's coming up the way
you're 10 years ahead of them and you
could say these are the mistakes that i
made yeah
i can help you get through this and then
you see them flourish there's a great
deal
of personal satisfaction oh definitely
there's got to be some sort of an
evolutionary benefit to this kind of
people that's well that's part of
see that's the thing is we are evolved
for reciprocity
we really are we're not evolved for
power right right this is this is what's
so deeply wrong about the damn
post-modernists and the marxist is that
that isn't what human first of all power
is not
the best strategy to attain success it's
simply not it doesn't even work for
chimpanzees because
the more the brute chimps you know the
ones that that rule purely as a
consequence of force
as soon as they weaken two subordinates
that are reciprocally
engaged so that have a friendship tear
them into pieces so i don't care how
strong you are
three guys that are like two-thirds your
strength are going to take you out
so so you're much better situated
in in society and in your life if you if
you're
in an interactive network of
reciprocally
beneficial relationships that works in
games but it also works in life
and to reduce that and and if you're
competent so there's
there's the the killer combination hyper
competence
and the capacity for genuine reciprocity
that makes you unstoppable
why is there this lack of understanding
and appreciating this nuance in people
that oppose these ideas
like what is what's the willingness to
be ignorant
about all the variabilities especially
when you consider the bulk of the
research well i think some of it's
justification for failure
you know like if you're not doing very
well then it's really easy to think that
the game is rigged
it's also easy to be resentful about
people who seem to have more than you
have
especially if you're not thinking about
it very clearly you know and that's
another thing that
i've been trying to lecture to people
about is that you should be very careful
about assuming that someone else has
more than you do
i mean one of the best predictors of
whether someone has money is how old
they are
so old people are richer than young
people well obviously right because they
had their whole life to accrue wealth
it's like well who's got it better
you want to be rich and old or young and
poor
you know i mean you can't buy youth with
money
so it isn't obvious who's better off in
a situation like that
it's in in fact i think most people who
are old and rich would trade it for
young and poor
fairly damn quickly well that's why
people really get angry when they see
young rich people yeah
i know that's just too much to bear yeah
like a young rich
famous rapper like uh what's that fella
this 17 year old a little pump how about
that
famous 17. but you know the first in
high school
well the funny thing too though is that
you know even with people who have that
that sort of
let's call it good fortune um you know
independent of of their talent you don't
have to scratch beneath the surface very
far
even in successful people's lives until
you find a pretty decent vein of tragedy
you know and so it it that jealousy of
of of the successful is also based on a
really unidimensional
view of exactly what constitutes success
you know you see the
the trappings whatever they might be
let's say it's a yacht and
and more money than you know what to do
with and you assume well that's going to
put that person at the pinnacle of a
satisfying life but
there's no shortage of dreadfully
unhappy and addicted
celebrities and it isn't obvious always
that more money is good for people
you know i mean you say oh that's a
problem i'd like to have it's like look
fair enough i mean there are worse
problems but
celebrity and fame and fortune are also
not that easy to deal with and they come
with their own pitfalls plus
there's lots of things they don't
protect you against you know people
still get divorced and they still get
sick and they still die and their
parents still get alzheimer's and all of
that like the
the fundamental tragic elements of life
are still in place
one of the interesting things about
people that are jealous of other people
that are extremely successful is that
you're missing one of the core lessons
of
competition one of the core lessons of
competition is to be inspired by those
who are more successful and not to try
to chip them down and take away
their accomplishments because they don't
make you
feel good yeah the people that are
piss-poor at competition
are always the ones that are trying to
diminish the accomplishments of those
who are extremely successful
you see this in sports fans if you see a
loser fat sports fan talking about
what a piece of [ __ ] lebron james is
because he dropped the ball
or he missed a shot like this the
extreme
reaction that they could have to someone
who's extraordinarily successful
is almost always in direct proportion to
how much of a failure they are in their
own life
and that's one of the reasons why in
contrast it looks so ridiculous
yeah well that's part of the danger i
would say that's part of the danger of
the entire
identity politics movement is that you
know
is that that reasonable care for the
dispossessed which we already talked
about is easily contaminated by hatred
and resentment for people who are
not only successful but who are the most
annoying
person who's successful is the person
who deserves it not the person who
doesn't deserve it
because you can write the person who
doesn't deserve it off right the lottery
winner
you can say oh yeah well you know he
just got lucky yeah exactly
but then you see the person who's broken
themselves in half and you know come out
of a really
pathological background and has been
successful and you're like you're you're
uselessly um wasting your life away
that's the sort of person that you
really don't like because they cast you
in a very dim
light so this is where competition is so
important because the person that has a
background in competition has been
involved in competition
sees a person who's busted their ass and
and
becomes something really extraordinary
and it's incredibly inspirational
and you look to those people and you
want to read their biography
and you want to watch documentaries on
them because it literally gives you fuel
whereas the person who who shies away
from competition is afraid of their own
insecurities and failures
and really has never tested themselves
those are the ones that find these
people
extremely distasteful because when they
put themselves
in comparison to these incredible people
they they come up short yeah well every
idea
exercises every idea is a judge yes and
so what's what's the answer to that
no ideals that's a stupid that's a
stupid suggestion no it certainly
doesn't because then it leaves people
without any meaning in their life
you know so well i think it speaks to
what you were talking about earlier that
we need adversity
that we need adversity we need
difficulty we need struggle you need you
need a weight to carry
and if you don't have any of this you do
not get your character tested
you do not advance in your own
perception of who you are
in this world and how you how you engage
with all the other people around you you
don't call out what's best in you
yes and then and then you can't live
without that you need that
you need that and so and the trick seems
to be that
voluntary acceptance of the adversity
see that's one of the things that i
think is
core to the mythos of christianity
because there's an idea that you should
pick up your cross and stumble uphill
and that's really what that means is
that you you know you set your you set
your eyes on
some high level vision the city of god
on the hill whatever that happens to be
you know
and then you take the burden whatever
burden you're capable of lifting which
is obviously going to be a burden of
suffering at least to some degree and
you carry that
voluntarily that's the trick is that and
then you say well you need a purpose in
your life it's like well look there's a
lot of problems around you in the world
you have some problems some problems
even that bother you right personally
they seem to call out to you those
problems
maybe those are your problems those are
the problems you should solve
and those i think are the call to
adventure it's like there's a problem it
bugs me okay
do something about it that's your
problem there's a certain amount that
you could tolerate i mean i think it's
like
weight training there's a certain amount
where it becomes detrimental
where you've over trained your body's
breaking down there's a certain amount
of problems you have in your life
that are extremely beneficial yeah
because through
going through these problems sorting
them out you you build your spirit you
you build your character
and if you don't accomplish anything and
you never encounter
any problems you you are this gelatinous
soft
atrophied soul and you don't have the
intestinal fortitude or the spirit or
the
the the human potential has not been
developed to the point where you can
overcome adversity
the only way to overcome adversity is to
face it so that that
optimum that you were talking about so
i've really been interested in the
neurophysiology of the of the sense of
meaning because neurophysiology yeah
yeah because the meaning the feeling of
meaning is an instinct right
it's not a thought it's not a secondary
consequence of rational processes it's
way deeper than that it's something that
drives rationality itself
so now you just vary amongst people
definitely yeah but it varies in this
way as far as i can tell so so
imagine as you said that there's an
optimal
load right you exceed that and to your
detriment
and you see that in the weight room you
pull a muscle you hurt or you'll hurt
yourself
you can injure yourself very badly right
you can take yourself out for the count
um but then if you if you work too
little well then there's no gain in it
you have to find that thin edge
where you're competent at what you're
doing but you're pushing yourself
that's going to be where meaning lies
that's what meaning tells people
it says you're on the edge where you're
competent and
and out of undue danger but pushing
yourself enough
so that you're continually developing
that's the instinctive meaning
and that looks to me like it's a
consequence of the interaction between
the right and the left hemispheres
and a consequence of the interaction
between the negative emotion systems
anxiety and pain that regulate you that
protect you from harm
and the exploratory and play systems
that drive you forward
you want the exploratory and play
systems to drive you forward
but then they're regulated by these
negative emotions so you don't hurt
yourself and if you get that optimally
right then that's the
maximal that's the point of maximal
challenge and that makes you really
alert because your positive emotion is
functioning that's what's driving you
forward
this is worth doing and your negative
emotions are alert too
saying yeah but be awake and be careful
and you know what that's like in the
weight room if
you know you're lifting something that's
at the edge of your ability you've got a
spotter
you want to push and you can barely do
it and you want to make sure that you're
not going to like
pull your arm down and rip the hell out
of your muscle but
you you're right on that edge and that's
the place of maximal gain
and that sense of meaning that's what
puts you on the border between chaos and
order
right because too much order means
you're just practicing what you already
know
and then you then you you stultify and
stagnate and too much chaos means
you better look out because you're going
to hurt yourself you're pushing yourself
beyond your limits
you stay right on that edge that's where
there's maximal meaning
and then you're entirely trying to get
edges just push it to push it yeah
now one of the things i recommend to
young people especially true for people
in their 20s is that
you should push yourself beyond your
limits of tolerance in your 20s
to find out where it is how much can you
work how disciplined can you become
like can you work 12 hours a day can you
work eight hours a day can you work
three hours a day like flat out
where's your limit and how much how much
work can you do and how much
socialization
you should find out push yourself past
and then
back off to that point where it's
optimally sustainable that's what a lot
of people do isn't it i mean they party
too much when they're in their 20s they
make a lot of mistakes
it's it's what they're doing and i would
say in sort of a haphazard way
right because there's that instinct to
go out there and do more
right and but it's it's unregulated and
it's not
it's not as self-conscious as it might
be it's good to know that there's
it's good to think about that as a goal
it's like you're trying to discover what
your limitations are when you're when
you're in your 20s
so that you can hit that edge so that
you can sustain yourself across the
decades
and so yeah because you don't you don't
want to you don't want to have too much
fun
all right too much fun takes you out you
don't want to be the oldest guy at the
disco
you know it's not it's not fun being the
40 year old at the singles bar
precisely so you want to make sure that
what you're doing is age appropriate and
you want to push yourself in every
direction that you can but you should be
doing that with an aim in mind it's like
you're trying to make yourself into a
better and more competent person
and so some discipline along with the
fun is a good idea
so to take care of yourself and the
people around you that's a one of the
things i recommended to people and i've
had quite a few people
actually tell me that they've done this
interestingly enough i said well one
thing you could aim at if you had any
sense when you were young is to be the
most worth you could be the most
reliable person at your father's funeral
and so i think that's a good challenge
and i had a bunch of people come up to
me in this last tour and tell me that
that's exactly what they did these were
often young guys you know like
before 20. said my dad died suddenly or
you know he died after a year's
illness and it was just taking me out
and no wonder you know
he said i said i was listening to your
lectures you said you want to be the
most reliable person at the funeral
because everyone else is grieving and
what the hell else are you going to do
he said that's what they tried to do and
that got him through it
so well that's part of that picking up
that load as far as i'm concerned
you get a little self-respect out of
that too in a real sense right because
you know you're this sort of sad
suffering creature that's capable of
a fair bit of malevolence but if you
find out that you can
carry a heavy load and take care of
yourself and have a little left over for
some other people then you can wake up
at three in the morning and think well
man
i could be worse and this is not a
political perspective this is a positive
constructive way of looking at how to
navigate
the world but when you break down
these sort of behavior types whether
it's the people that generally support
socialism
or socialist ideas or their
anti-competition
versus people that are pro-pushing
yourself
they fall into these right-wing
left-wing sort of paradigms
in this really weird way that i mean
especially that i think that's
especially true on the radical ends but
i think you get that on the radical
right too because you get people who are
who are collectivist in their
fundamental orientation you know and
they're
they're trying to take undue credit for
who their racial ancestors were
or okay what what i would say with the
with the political issue is that i think
that you can build
decent responsible people who are on the
middle right of the spectrum and the
middle left you know because i think
that you can have
left-wing political beliefs that are
genuinely
aimed at aid to the dispossessed without
being resentful of the hierarchies
and without contaminating it with
jealousy for the successful
it's hard right you you have to because
when i worked for the
ndp when i was a kid when that was the
socialist party in canada
the leaders some of the leaders were
people like that
like a lot of the low-level party
functionary types they were the activist
types that you still see today and
they're mostly resentful i didn't like
them at all
but some of the leaders were genuinely
genuine advocates for the working class
you know and they they had their flaws
obviously but
but their they put their money where
their mouth was and they were trying to
ensure that the hierarchies were open to
advancement for
for for let's say the common person so
to speak the person who stacked up at
the bottom
or for their children which might even
be more important you know so that the
hierarchies remain
open to genuine competition
based on competence which would be a
perfectly reasonable
thing for the left to insist on right is
that let's bloody well make sure that
it's a fair game
and so that people don't get locked out
of movement forward because of arbitrary
positions of power
right and that's that's that's a
reasonable that's a reasonable
part of the discussion so i think if you
build better people you can build better
people on the left and on the right and
people that are
going to appreciate that rules to the
game are better for everyone they're
better for the people that win they're
better for the people that are coming up
they're better forever yes if you have
to have real structure and real rules
and that you're better off being a guy
like wayne gretzky yes
better off being a guy who's respected
who plays the game correctly and just
does his best and really truly becomes a
champion and love by all because of it
you're better off in every way right
right and that's the most state the
other thing that's so cool about that so
imagine this this is the antidote to
moral relativism
okay so the first thing is is that
there are real problems and and
hierarchical organizations can offer
real solutions
socially and personally so you can
confront the problems courageously and
you can solve them
so that's real it ameliorates suffering
and limits malevolence and so there's
nothing morally relative about that
the second is that sense of meaning that
we discussed
that's not some philosophical second
order consequence of thinking
it's way deeper than that that sense of
meaning tells you
when you're vygotsky this russian
psychologist called that the zone of
proximal development which i believe is
where the phrase the zone came from
and so in the zone of proximal
development this is what adults do with
children
little kids that are learning to talk
adults automatically talk to little
children who are learning to talk
at a level that slightly exceeds their
current vocabulary
they do that without even knowing it and
that puts those kids in the zone right
because if you just talk baby talk to
kids then all they learn is baby talk
and if you just talk like an adult then
they don't understand a word you're
saying
so you'll find this happy medium in
between where the kid mostly understands
what you're talking about
and that you're pulling them forward so
that puts them in the zone and that's a
meaningful zone
and so you can feel the operation of
that zone in your own life that's what
the taoists are on about
because they say well you dow is the way
right and that's the pathway between
chaos and order
that's meaning and you can feel that in
your life when you're deeply engaged in
something like we have deeply engaging
conversations
okay which is part of the reason that we
keep having them and i think why they're
popular
and we're not paying attention to how
the clock is ticking or how time is
flowing or even
to the fact that we're doing what we're
doing we're just having a conversation
and it's meaningful it's engaged it
keeps our eyes focused and our senses
um concentrated on what's happening and
the reason for that is that
there's enough information flowing
between us so that we're being slightly
transformed as a consequence of the
discussion
right so we're both comfortable we trust
each other
we trust that the conversation is aimed
at something that's of mutual benefit
we trust each other to tell the truth to
to to the degree that we're capable of
doing that
and then when you engage in this
exchange of information and to the
degree that it's
breaking you down a little bit and
building you up in a different way
that's a little death and rebirth
there's constant little deaths and
rebirths in a meaningful conversation
then that keeps you alive and
functioning and that
that focuses you like that that speaks
to you so deeply that that focus happens
without any consciousness and that's
meaning and that's that line between
chaos and order and that's real
that has nothing it's it's a it's and i
would say
here's another thing that's cool so that
line between chaos and order
that's the same thing that's happening
when you're playing a game properly
right because you're in the game and
you're you're exercising your skill but
you're pushing it
but you're pushing it in a way that's
also a benefit to your teammates and to
the
progression of the game as such and to
being a better general player you're
doing all that at the same time
and you're evolved with enough natural
intelligence
so that the sum total output of your
nervous system
says to you you're in the right place at
the right time doing the right thing
and that's what makes your life
meaningful and that's real and i think
it's more real than anything else
i think it's more real than suffering i
think it's more real than malevolence
because it's the antidote to both of
those
and so the whole moral moral relativism
issue for me is a
non-starter it's just wrong there's lots
of ways of interpreting the world but
there aren't very many ways of
interpreting it
optimally and you can feel when you're
doing that it makes you stronger
and then the people that come to me
after my talks and say well you know
i've been putting my life together
i've developed a vision i've been trying
to be more responsible i've been trying
to be more honest and put my
relationships together
they're all sparkly-eyed because of this
or crying sometimes
because it's really had an impact at the
moment on them at a deep level they
think oh wow this actually works it's
like yeah it actually works it's
real it's real and i would say as well
that that's associated with the idea of
the deep western idea of the logos which
is meaning
in action and speech so you know if we
have a conversation that's meaningful
then that's a manifestation of the
spirit of the logos and that's the thing
that
destroys an and and recreates
at the same time because you learn
something it destroys something
destroys a little presupposition that
you had that was erroneous and replaces
it with something that's healthier
and every time you have a meaningful
conversation that happens it's like a
little tweak
now it wasn't quite right here click
that moves and something new takes its
place
so and that's a little death and rebirth
instead of the catastrophic death and
rebirth that you might have to have if
you weren't paying attention
so that's all tied together that's all
tied together with that phenomena of
meaning and that's the same as the
adoption of responsibility
that all ties together so not so nicely
yeah the concept of meaning
like what is important that it's so it's
so huge to people but so fleeting
it's so difficult to like what is
meaning well you know there's the simple
ones right like family and loved ones
and companionship and
community and finding something that you
enjoy
doing that you know you can do that
seems bigger than you or bigger than
yourself but
but meaning like the meaning of life
what is meaning and this it's one of the
things that gives people so much
existential angst
and i i think is the cause of a lot of
despair because there's
well you can question it yes but the the
thing is is that that's one of the
dangers of rationality is that
see the egyptians associated the
catholics did this to some degree too
they associated ration
rationality with a proclivity to
malevolence
partly because rationality tends to fall
in love with its own productions
intelligence has this like inbuilt
arrogance and the egyptians in
particular were really
in insightful they tried to replace the
idea of
intelligence as the highest virtue with
the idea of attention as the highest
virtue this is something eldest huxley
knew
he wrote a book called island island was
an island that was populated by
had a lot of birds on it and the birds
could talk and all they did was say pay
attention
to remind everybody on the island to pay
attention all the time but
you you can undermine your sense of
meaning and you can question it but
the best thing to do is to actually pay
attention to when it manifests itself
because it's a it's a phenomenon like
like
color or like or like love or like
beauty it it exists
it isn't something you create it's
something that you discover and you can
discover it
you just have to watch like you're
ignorant about yourself you think okay
well i'm gonna
i i've told my clinical clients to do
this and my students is
watch yourself for two weeks just watch
like you don't know who you are
and notice when you're doing something
that you're engaged in
it's like you'll see it maybe it's only
10 minutes because your life is pretty
out of balance but you'll see that oh
man i was engaged in something there for
minutes it's like why what was what did
you do that was right that engaged you
you were in the right place at the right
time doing the right thing for a few
minutes
what was it what were the preconditions
there's this line
in the new testament christ says the
kingdom of god is spread
across the earth but men do not see it
and that's what it refers to
is that you you you wander into paradise
now and then
when you're engaged and you're deeply
engaged in something but you don't
notice it
you don't think oh look i'm in the right
place and everything's working out right
now it means
i've got it right somehow and then i
need to practice
being there more and more and more which
is
well that's the appropriate thing to try
to practice and that's to make
that's to come to some negotiated
what would you call it it's do it it's
to come to a negotiation with that
intrinsic sense of meaning and to
realize
it as a fact rather than just as an
opinion
or or something that's secondary because
it's annoying concept for people though
to be so aware
of who they are and what they're doing
they could recreate that
so when they do feel that feeling of
meaning that they could figure out a way
to get back into that state and what
were all the extenuating circumstances
and
where was my head at what caused me to
have this this feeling like things were
right yes well it's like someone gives
you a gift and you think well i'd like
that gift again it's like yeah well you
have to figure out
what it was that you did to deserve it
so to speak and yeah i know it requires
a
fair bit of it requires a fair bit of
careful reflection
but it also requires that ignorance is
you have to think well i don't know who
i
am i'm going to find some things
meaningful what are they
they might not even be things you want
to find meaningful they might be things
that you might even be ashamed of
you know because sometimes people are
interested in things that they don't
think that they should be interested in
like
maybe you'll you'll have a guy who is
who was is kind of a cliche but who was
um you know socialized to be a real
tough guy and he finds out that he's
kind of interested in art
or aesthetics it's like well he's
ashamed of that because maybe it's too
feminine or
whatever well it's doesn't matter
because that's actually speaking that
that's actually something that's
speaking to him from the core of his
genuine being he's going to have to
pursue that or you might find
you know that someone who's really
agreeable and kind of a pushover
stands up to someone just once at work
says what they really think and then
they realize afterwards wow you know
that was exactly right then they think
oh my god you know i've decided when i
was a little kid maybe they had a harsh
father and they decided when they were
four i'm never going to be angry in my
whole life
there's something wrong with aggression
so they've gone out of their way their
whole life to be
free of conflict then they find out the
one day they stand up for themselves
that that whole domain that they'd
parsed off as inappropriate is actually
contains exactly what they need to put
themselves together
but you find what you need where you
least want to look that's the old
alchemical dictum
instir qualis inventure right i want to
talk to you about
activists because it's something that
you brought up earlier saying that you
you you know you find them unappealing
like i want to know
what you think the motivation of
a lot of these like particularly radical
left-wing activists
that want to shut down lectures and
scream people down and
you know in these uh auditoriums what do
you think the motivation of these people
is
and what do you what do you think is the
root of it
well i think that it's a quick route to
moral virtue
you know like it's actually really hard
to put yourself together and you have to
do that in ways that you can't trump it
you know because most of the things that
are wrong with you are kind of
low what would you call it second rate
and embarrassing
you're all your stupid little habits and
your proclivity to procrastinate and all
the things that you're minorly ashamed
of
and then you have to work on those
slowly because you the probability that
you're going to be able to fix them
quickly is
low and you can't really brag about it
because
it's so embarrassing just to admit that
they exist to begin with that you can
hardly brag about it and
it's sort of painstaking private work
and
you you don't get a lot of social you
don't get a lot of quick social status
for it
it's effortful embarrassing humbling
and difficult and then you can do
something
like be an activist and you get all that
public acclaim for being
on the good side with no effort
whatsoever
and so it's a plus do you think that
there's any motivation at all to try to
make the world a better place
yes i think that's that's part of it
sure well i think
it's flavored by this desire to
broadcast your virtue yes because it's
very difficult to make the world a
better place
you know that's the thing is no i mean
young people have a messianic
impulse that's another thing that was
documented by piaget that
there's a stage you know in late
adolescence where you want to make the
world a better place and
i would say that's probably part of the
impulse
to you know establish a permanent
relationship
and have a family and and and take care
of people you know
and and to take on some of the burden of
life it's it's the
psychological precursor to that and it's
reasonable for
smart young people to be concerned about
broader philosophical issues if they
tilt in that direction as well
but it's all too easy for that to be
pathologized into resentment for
for those who seem to have more unfairly
and also to take the easy route out and
there aren't easy routes there are only
difficult routes to doing
useful things and it's better just to do
that
and then so i think that there's some
impulse to you know there's some wish
that things could be less unfair and
that fewer people could suffer
but it's kind of a low level virtue that
that reflects of compassion
you know i i'm not saying it's it's
without merit because it's the
that compassion is the basis for the
ability to take care of
of people who are ill and and and
infants and so feel this low level like
where's that it's not thought through
things are complicated it's hard to it's
hard to make complicated systems work
better
and it's really easy to make them work
worse what about activists that want
to shut down certain speakers like
someone who's
uh in my opinion uh fairly innocuous
uh in in terms of the the net like
here's one christina hoff summers i just
i don't see a good argument for shutting
her down she's so polite
she's a feminist she's well-read yeah
she's a
really nice person yeah janice femenko
is like that too in the canada
yeah some sort of person doesn't make
sense that people would shout her down
yet they do oh yeah
they shout her down they say horrible
things about her they mischaracterize
her
in a a really brutal way that
it completely invalidates their argument
or their
opposition to her to anyone that's
paying attention to what she said
oh well a lot of it is a lot of it is a
lot of it is also just immature acting
out
yes you know and there's an arrogance
it's tolerated
very strange way yeah yeah it is it is
it is well
yeah it's it's it's
part of our doubt i suppose about
authority and about its
and our our willingness to assume that
all authority is contaminated by power
it's like it's nation heckling too it's
almost like like you're if you're doing
a play
you know or a musical or you're singing
a song someone just decided to start
screaming out well that person's an
[ __ ]
but if you're espousing an opinion yeah
and that person decides to scream out
and they they do so
under the guise of moral virtue yeah
yeah
undeserved access to power yes you know
and it's no wonder that the radical
leftists in particular
concentrate on power everything's about
power well then it's okay if they use
power
as part of their means of expression
it's like well you're just playing power
games
it's perfectly reasonable even
appropriate for me to play power games
because you know i'm oppressed compared
to you
if everything's power then everybody
gets to yell right and there's no
one of the things i realized about about
recently as well is that
there isn't a debate about free speech
exactly not the way that we think about
it you know you know because the
there's the classical defense of free
speech so the classical defense of free
speech is that
it's better for both of us if we're able
to exchange our opinions because
i have the opportunity to learn from you
and you have the opportunity to learn
from me
from your own mistakes and social
feedback
and so do i and negotiation beats war
okay so that's kind of the classical now
but that's predicated on some
assumptions and those are
you're an autonomous being you're
capable of formulating an opinion that
that's actually unique to you
and that in dialogue we can mutually
modify
each other's unique opinions in a way
that produces
a mutually harmonious and beneficial
outcome that's all the predicate
well the the people who are opposed to
free speech you see
it's not that they're trying to shut
down people whose opinions are different
than theirs exactly
it's that they're opposed to the idea
that free speech
exists it's a way deeper problem
because at the bottom of the
postmodernist mess is
the following assumption is that well
there's no
there's no one way of interacting with
the world that's preferable to any other
way and so what people do is organize
themselves into hierarchies of power
and then struggle for dominance within
the hierarchies and then the hierarchy
struggle between each other
so it's a landscape of warring
hierarchies that's all it is
and you think that you're a person and
that you have an opinion
but you're not you're just the
mouthpiece of your
privileged hierarchy and so am i
and so and it's incommensurate if we're
from different hierarchies
there isn't a you talking to a me that
could come to an agreement
there's just you acting as a mouthpiece
for your power and me acting as a
mouthpiece for my power
and so since i'm part of my group and i
want to win because it's all about power
then why the hell would i ever want you
to talk it's not like i have anything to
learn from you or even that learning is
possible or even that there are two
people having a discussion
there's nothing but the mouthpiece of
power
there's two mouthpieces of power warring
and so that why should i listen to you
i'll just shut you down because then i
win
and so this this free speech debate
isn't about
who whose opinion should be allowed
within
you know an overarching framework where
free speech is
is a real thing it's a debate about
whether there's such a thing as free
speech at all
the the radical post-modernist types
they deny even that there's such a thing
as an autonomous individual in any way
you're just you're just the nexus of
economic forces
economic and social forces you're
entirely socially constructed
there's no you these are deep criticisms
like i've made this case before that the
post-modern types
although they have to ally themselves
with the marxist for for reasons that we
don't have to go into
they are going after things that are so
fundamental you can't believe it
they don't there is no autonomous
individual in the post-modern world
that's a that's a modernist or an
enlightenment viewpoint that's or a
christian viewpoint or a judeo-christian
viewpoint
or maybe an abrahamic religion viewpoint
who the hell knows it might be that
that that deep you're the nexus of
sociological forces
there's no integrated self you don't
have ideas or opinions
and there's no dialogue between us that
doesn't exist
there's your group your identity your
struggle for power
and that's all this is your
interpretation
no no this is this is the fundamental
essence of post-modernism
especially it's especially true in the
format espoused by daradan foucault
foucault everything's about power
everything's about power
and daredevil was definitely that's why
he criticized the idea of logocentrism
logos is that ability of the individual
to engage in dialogue
the root for dialogue is logos or logic
that's all criticized that's all gone
the identity politics players the
serious
the people who are serious about this
philosophically they don't believe in
the idea of the autonomous individual
that's gone so it's not like they're
playing a game within
you know you think well this is a game
we're all playing a game where we agree
on some things and and we're just
disagreeing about the details it's like
oh no
no no no you don't want to make that
mistake this this critique is way way
deeper than that which is why darada was
opposed to the idea of logocentrism he
didn't believe in the idea of an
autonomous individual
that didn't exist that's just a fiction
set up by those
who have used the idea of the autonomous
individual to advance
their power maneuvering within the
uh confines of the colonialist
the colonialist west now and what's the
rationalization for that perspective is
this to enhance
their argument to try to to push forth
their ideas
in a less less debatable way like
why i think the motivation is hatred for
competence hatred for competence i truly
believe that i've been trying to go down
like go down as deep as i could to find
out i think it's cane and able
wow i really believe that i think that
because i can't understand the
motivation otherwise it's like well why
are you tearing these things down well
it's
on the basis you know we have sympathy
for the oppressed it's like well
well why like where in your where in
your conceptualization
does that idea of sympathy for the
oppressed come from you don't even have
the idea of the individual in your
conceptualization
it's like that's just a
i i don't i don't i don't buy any of
that i i think it's cain and abel
all the way down do you think that when
you're talking about the scandinavian
model
where they've made it incredibly
equal and through this
massive effort to take away
any opportunity or to to to rather open
up every possible opportunity for women
that men also have and you've seen these
these
differences in genders actually
accentuate because of this
do you think that maybe
what we're seeing also even in terms of
the post-modernists and the radical
leftists versus people on the right
this same sort of competition aspect of
it is also
problematic because it's one of the
reasons why there's so much
debate in the first place and that if we
if we had
maybe more middle ground and more
opportunity there would be
less of an argument there would be less
of a reason
to have these these these extreme polar
opposites
that may be embracing of more like
there's certain
socialist uh aspects of our society that
we just accept right
like the fire department right yeah like
police universal provision of
infrastructure yes yeah that's a good
one schools should be i think more
emphasized in that direction
but it it gears towards
privatized schools for people with
higher incomes which gets
away more from socialism and sort of
reinforces capitalism more right
but i think things like maybe perhaps
even universal basic income
or certainly universal healthcare with
you which you guys have in canada which
we don't have here
and definitely a higher education
making higher education far more
accessible and far less costly
stop subsidizing these student loans
stop making student loans something that
you can never escape well i think this
is part of the eternal debate right
because
we've already talked about the utility
of hierarchies and the necessity of
putting those who can
in charge but the consequence of that
which is an unequal distribution of
both talent and resources well you don't
want that to get so steep that people
stack up at the bottom because your
whole society starts to destabilize and
so you have to have a continual
discussion between the left and the
right
to see how you stop the bottom from
suffering yeah from from hitting zero
yeah because zero's not good you can't
play when you hit zero
and that's not good and so i don't think
there is a
universal solution to that problem
because the problem keeps manifesting
it's
think about it as an eternal problem
here's the problem
there's a set of problems that'll never
go away now
what the problems are change but the
fact that there are problems never go
away
okay the fact that you have to produce
hierarchies to solve those problems
never goes away
the fact that the hierarchies dispossess
but the details shift all the time and
so
the whole reason that you need the
political discussion is to
take a look at the particulars of the
hierarchies and the particulars of the
dispossession and say okay well now we
need to shim it up here and now we need
to shim it up here and now we need to
adjust this and now we need to adjust
this because
you can't come up with a final solution
to those problems
i think that's partly why you have
consciousness itself
you know because if you could automate
the solution
imagine there was a permanent solution
well there's a permanent solution to
breathing
you have a part of your brain that just
breathes you don't think about it you
don't adjust it while you do a bit when
you're talking but you get my point it's
like
problem taken care of well there's other
problems that are so
fluid like they're eternal problems but
they're so fluid in their detail that
you need awareness
and linguistic capacity to address them
and i would say the problem of
hierarchy and dispossession fit exactly
into that category
is that we're going to organize
ourselves hierarchically because talent
is unequally distributed
it doesn't matter like as soon as you
invent basketball and instantly
you know there's one percent of the
population who are super great at
basketball
it doesn't matter as soon as you set up
an arbitrary value structure you get a
hierarchy
then there's the whole schlubs at the
bottom that can't put a ball in the
hoop to save their lives and and
that's an eternal problem that's why it
says in the new testament that the poor
will be with us
always a very pessimistic if there's two
lines like that one
is to those who have everything more
will be given and from those who have
nothing everything will be taken
that's a rough line and the second is
the poor will be with us always
okay so why well it's a reflection of
what we just described is that
you're going to get hierarchical
structures and they're going to
dispossess okay so then what we want to
do is we want to use
mercy say justice gives you what you
deserve
so that's on the competitive end you get
what you deserve
but there's this old idea an old
religious idea this is a good idea
god rules with two hands right hand is
justice and the left hand is mercy
justice means you get what you deserve
but the world can't survive that way
because people are flawed
and make mistakes and if you only got
exactly what you deserved
it would be a hell of a world right
because you'd be punished for every
single mistake you make
you know you'd be held accountable in a
way that would be unbearable
so that has to be tempered with mercy
and and so maybe the left is the is the
end of the distribution that tempers
with mercy
when it's functioning properly but it
can degenerate into
that cane-like resentment of the of the
successful and that's a danger on the
right you have the opposite danger which
is well
you know you advance because of your
competence but then
that can ossify and so you want to hang
on to that that position even though you
know
your competence no longer justifies it
you start to use
the advantages of your position to
accrue benefits for yourself that you
did not earn
and that's the proclivity of the of the
hierarchy to become blind and tyrannical
and that's a that's an eternal problem
the the egyptians had a god for that
osiris
osiris was the god of hierarchies and he
was always threatened by seth who was
his evil brother
and his evil brother was always
conspiring to overcome him and that's
the problem with hierarchies is that
they
tilt towards tyranny and the the
reasonable left says that
watch the hierarchies because they tilt
towards tyranny it's like yes
it's true but that doesn't mean that
the idea of hierarchy itself is flawed
and that doesn't mean that
all hierarchies are tyrannical that's
going way too far
do you think that the scandinavian model
that has revealed
that when you do make things more equal
you will find that people generally
tend to gravitate more towards
traditional gender roles
that the the does this do you think that
this
makes people happier has it been
observed that this is a
a happier result that's a good question
the the um indices of life satisfaction
are pretty high in scandinavia
but i don't know if anybody has done an
analysis that would indicate
whether the the sexual sorting
is a contributor to that that's a good
question
i mean the the general idea has been
that
the scandinavians are happier because
their societies are more egalitarian
but but they're not more egalitarian
in the sense that men and women are also
more different
so men and women are more different but
the opportunities
are more egalitarian yeah yeah yeah so
but so then but and then the societies
are more
are more satisfied but it's tough
because there's other variables because
the scandinavian countries are
relatively homogenous
right and more homogeneous societies
tend to be um
more peaceful and happier not not more
diverse societies
and they're also small countries so
they're somewhat easier to govern
right and they tend to be wealthy
so those so it'd be hard to parse out
all those contributors right to figure
out what it is that's making the
scandinavians relatively
um content this is almost like a super
tribe
versus a country yeah yeah right well
and those those sorts of societies in
some sense are easier to manage
so there any benefit to this this
model that we could perhaps bring to the
united states or to canada
and maybe mitigate some of the issues
that we have
between the right and the left like
maybe there's some sort of a compromise
that'll lead to uh a less less debate
and dispute
well i think that you guys in the states
are doing real well
actually personally i mean
you know your your system of checks and
balances seems to work out pretty well
there's a fair bit of let's say left
domination right now of
of the mainstream media i think that's a
reasonable claim and also of academia
and of the intelligentsia but the
political system is skewed pretty hard
to the republican end of things at the
moment
and so that's not a bad balance and then
in the last election
i mean it maybe you could make a case
perhaps
that things had tilted a little too far
to the republican side
but that got balanced out because the
hou the democrats took the house again
and it seems like they were more
moderate democrats that seems to be the
scuttlebutt so you know it isn't obvious
to me that your system isn't functioning
well
i think that one of the things that's
happening
that's making things look more
contentious than they are
is that the mainstream media is under
such assault by the
up and coming media forms including
people like you
that as their financial models
deteriorate and as their journalistic
standards take a hit and as they lose
their fact
checkers and their time to be careful
with the stories they concentrate more
on exaggerating the extremes
to attract attention and so you know
there was an article published in the
atlantic monthly about a month ago
showing that didn't it depends on how
you calculate these things but that the
radical leftists and the radical
right-wingers are only about five
percent of the population on each side
and that mo the vast majority of
americans consider themselves
something approximating the relatively
silent majority
and so i don't think that things are
polarized as
as badly as they seem and it
is also the case right now that if you
poll people and ask them about the
conditions of their
life in the united states they tend to
say that they're doing quite well
but that other people aren't and so i
think maybe
i don't know this for sure but but i
think maybe that
the technological pressure that's being
put on the mainstream media
is driving extreme political views as a
means of gathering the attention of a
shrinking market share
that's that's a very interesting take on
and i wonder how detrimental that is to
us
as a whole because we are constantly
dealing with this click
bait nonsense headline you know and
every every
everything is a dispute everything's a
war yeah everything well it's
nerve-wracking yes
yes you know i mean i noticed this years
ago because i i really stopped watching
the news
oh 25 years ago although i've been
heavily involved in the last two years
because i noticed that most of what
passed for news wasn't
because my sense was well if it isn't
important in a month
if it isn't important a month from now
it was never important
and almost everything that's news is
like important right now
yeah and so i tried to stay away from
that it was better for my peace of mind
and i often
recommended to my clinical clients who
were depressed and anxious that they
shield themselves from the news as much
as possible
but now there's the news is everywhere
right it's everywhere it's twitter it's
facebook it's youtube it's like we're
just
inundated by it it's like cnn on
steroids it's
24-hour news cycle and it's produced by
everyone
whether they're um informed or not and
it's really high emotion and i think
that
that is making things look a lot worse
to us than they actually are
i think it's also similar to what we
were talking about earlier when it comes
to reading comments
on instagram or twitter i just think
there's just an amount of data yeah
that's incomprehensible i don't think
you can handle it i don't think you can
navigate it you can't navigate that many
relationships i mean these are the
reason why we have this dunbar's number
in our head
we if you're dealing with hundreds of
thousands of people in your case a
million followers that are constantly
interacting with you
it's going to [ __ ] drive you mad yeah
well you don't even know what to do with
it
you know like because i well i don't
even know what my ethical obligation is
to my twitter followers you know
because like there's a million people
following you so react to all of them no
definitely well certainly i know one
limitation which is that
having it drive me insane is probably
not
a good outcome for anyone except for
those who hoped that i would fall
let's say this is a personal thing right
because they're responding and they're
it's the mentions are to you personally
but in a lesser way perhaps but
is still also overwhelming is just the
sheer amount of information that's
available constantly about everything
there's there's a million stories every
day about every single thing that's
going on in your life
well everywhere everywhere on the whole
planet yeah and
where how are you supposed to navigate
that
how are you supposed to get through life
and concentrate on things that are truly
meaningful for you in the present moment
without being completely detached from
the outside world
it's this balance that people try to
find that is so
elusive it's so hard to figure out how
much to
watch how much of this political process
do i pay attention to
well that's the big technological
challenge yes you know i mean we thought
when i was a kid we thought oh my god
you know kids are sitting in front of
the television four hours a night
it's like well you ain't seen nothing
yet yeah right you know it's not all day
long no kidding
phones yeah all day long yeah and the
phones are so much more powerful than
television that they're well it's like a
typewriter compared to a computer
yes you know and yeah it's well and it's
it's it's so
so we don't know how to adjust to that
psychologically but
it's even worse than that because as
soon as you adjust
to the degree that you do the technology
changes on you right
so comes more mercy sure it's always
leading in that direction yeah yeah so
it's a real
i mean you know i see this especially
with parents who have teenage kids
it's like they know the phones aren't
you know i've been talking to some
teenagers lately about
about you know maybe these are kids that
are are getting bullied on
social media it's like i think well when
i was 14
you know it's kind of a rough time of
life and you go to school and you've got
your friends and you've got your enemies
and
then you come home and your friends
aren't there and neither are your
enemies
right right you're you're outside
there's an outside of that
yeah but now on social media there's no
outside
you know the one kid i was talking to
had moved schools
and it's doing quite well in the new one
but the people from
the person's old school are still after
them on social media
so you know and you think well just
don't use your phone it's like
yeah yeah you tell that to your teenager
you try not using your phone for a whole
day
yeah you think well the teenager is
going to be able to manage the phone
it's like no they're not
you can't manage the phone nobody can
manage the phone
it's not just teenagers my middle
daughter is 10 years old
and all of her friends have phones yep
all of them
there's like two of her friends that
don't have phones yeah and they come
over the house and we have a rule at our
house you can't use a phone
like once you get inside the house
there's no phone so your friends come
over the house they want to like
constantly be on their phone and
and we said like you can't do that yeah
and they look you're like what are you
talking about yeah this is my life
yeah yeah my life is my phone they want
to make twitter posts and instagram and
they want to do facebook and
yeah they want to snapchat with each
other with bunny ears on and
these kids are just doing this all day
long well and they are mastering the
technology
that's the other thing it's not
surprising that they're trying to adapt
to it
but but it's happening at a really early
age because if you're giving your kid a
phone you're not putting any parental
filters on it
you're allowing that kid to have full
access to google and the world wide web
and they're just gonna
if you give your kid a phone and you
don't think they'll know how to use the
phone better than you within a year
you're a fool
that's true you know they're gonna
they're gonna have that thing figured
out in ways that you haven't even
imagined so yeah
yeah you're not controlling it that's
for sure it's uh
it is a very extraordinarily
unprecedented time to
sort of navigate this world and i don't
think any
does not have been i mean civilizations
have a deal with worse things right in
terms of violence and
famine and disease but i don't think
anyone's had to deal with such a
like a a radically transformative
medium like this well we have this range
of possibilities well and you ain't seen
nothing yet right i mean this is just
getting going
well have you been watching the boston
dynamics videos yeah
oh my god there's about those guys in
here oh yeah i bet
i mean that the the amount of progress
they've made in five years is just
absolutely staggering i bet they smell
like sulphur and they don't even know
yeah
i bet you bring them in here like the
[ __ ] is going on these guys are doomed
well elon musk was on the podcast
talking about some new
development they're working on called
neural link and that this is some
radical new way of accentuating
bandwidth between human beings and
information and
just increasing the access to it and he
was very vague about it yeah
he said it was going to come out within
you know x amount of months
yeah well they've already you know there
are scientists who've already
managed direct brain to computer links
right so you can get monkeys for example
to move a robotic arm
and so and i suspect that you know
you're you can
you can learn to control single neurons
in your face
my suspicions are that we'll develop
technologies that'll be wearable that
won't have to be neural implants that
you'll be able to communicate with
neurally
and that's not very far down the road
and the uh
you know the the probability that we're
going to build
you know you know about uh what's his
name kurzweil's idea the singularity you
know
well it's a wild idea and it seems
somewhat improbable and
i had a friend who once told me that if
something's impossible then it won't
happen
you know there'll be something that will
come up to stop it that you won't expect
and maybe the singularity is one of
those things
but you know i know a lot of guys who
are in the
high-end computational world and a lot
of them are convinced that we're within
a decade of a machine that's as powerful
as a human brain and i know people have
been saying that for a long time but
jesus you know computers are getting
good at emotion recognition they're
getting really good at facial
recognition they can communicate with
one another they can imitate
those boston dynamic robots are pretty
damn impressive and they're mostly
autonomous
we've got all sorts of things that can
navigate on their own like these
autonomous cars like
all these things are they're coming
together real fast
have you ever watched black mirror on
netflix the only one i watched was the
one that outlined what the chinese are
now doing to their own people
oh yeah the crisper one yeah yeah no no
the one where
everything you do is rated and trying to
write the social network one
right right right yes which which is
quite frightening and
reasonably probable oh 100 probable um
i was talking about the one i think it's
called heavy metal it's about uh
autonomous robots that seek out people
and kill them
and you know these uh artificial
intelligence
people that are making these boston
dynamic robots and
you know the scariest one that i read
about was a darpa one
called the eater robot e-a-t-r
it operates on it uses as a fuel
it uses biological material as fuel
which means if you're kidding you're
kidding no i'm not kidding
e-a-c-r so this is going to be able to
eat dead bodies
in the field theoretically
and use it as fuel good oh good that
sounds like a fine thing to develop
[ __ ] imagine uh an army of
robotic armed artificially intelligent
things
corpse eaters eat corpses in order to
have fuel
to continue to kill well someone's
obviously imagining that
it's made i mean this is a real thing
yeah well i mean part of the reason that
i'm doing what i'm doing with regards to
these lectures is you know i think that
we're in a time of unparalleled
possibility
right so for good and for and for evil
and that the more people that there are
out there who have their acts together
the better the probability that we're
going to be able to manage it
because we've all got some pretty hard
decisions to make coming up real fast
you know and these guys that are working
on these ai systems
i'm hoping that the ones that are more
ethically oriented in a proper direction
i'll be the ones that have the upper
hand
i'm really hoping that so yeah
collectively and what's the matter i was
looking into it because this
that came up before that it it breaks
the geneva conventions if they actually
eat dead bodies you can't do that yeah
whatever it's like once we have a robot
war dude that's
even conventions out the window yeah no
i couldn't agree with you more and i
think personally this is important and
collectively it's very important
that i mean i just think it's i think
what you wrote
12 rules to life we need rules we need
rules to be able to figure out how to
navigate this thing
that's complicated well that's why i
think that the individual level of
analysis is the right one is that i'm
hoping that
you know that like every time someone
comes up and talks to me and says look
you know i was in a dark place and i got
my life together and this is how it's
going i think
that tilts the scales non-trivially
towards a good outcome yes and the more
people that that's happening to the
better
and i don't think there's a more
effective way of doing it than to
concentrate on
the individual no i don't think there is
either and it's happening a lot
you know i i hear it every day i hear it
every day with people that find you
and find a lot of other inspirational
people online and just
jocko and there's just so many of them
there's so many and there's so much fuel
now for inspiration yeah so it's pretty
it's
pretty fun that that inspiration could
become popular
yeah it's crazy you saw this coming no
kidding no kidding and encouragement and
one of the things that's quite sad is
how little encouragement people need and
it's so touching you know because i'm
constantly in a state of
like being overwhelmed well even with
what happened this morning when i went
to whole foods you know because it's
overwhelming to have people come up and
like they share these really intimate
pieces of their life with you in like 20
seconds you know it's like
like you're an old friend you know and
it's like here's what my life was like
it's dark you know it's dark and like
here's a bunch of good things that are
happening it's like this little blast of
it's like the the persona of the person
disappears and you get to see the real
person there for like 20 seconds it's
like it's it's really it's overwhelming
but every time that happens as far as
i'm concerned it's a victory
and it's a victory that multiplies too
as far as i'm concerned so
i'm hoping that well every little bit
helps you know
that's it certainly does and by the way
if you meet me and you have one of those
stories and i don't know how to react
that's just how it is you know i go wow
that's amazing yeah well that's
that's good enough man i'm super happy
for you that's it i'm
genuinely happy for you but i still
don't know how to react that's how to
react
i don't i never will learn that's how to
that's how to react that's all you need
is like that's great man i hope you keep
doing it that's all my power too yeah
and it always feels
flat you know i mean like what they said
it's so mind-blowing and i'm saying
terrific
yeah but it is terrific it is terrific
yes it is it is
absolutely we just did another three
hours it's gone thank you sir
always please good to see you george
peterson you're a good man it's a
pleasure to be thank you everybody
bye thanks very much
[Music]
[Applause]